at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
what up you guys it's Wednesday and
we're doing another [__] paranormal
shows Zach has already been confused and
you made me doubt myself because I knew
that like this week it just so happened
we didn't do this on purpose or anything
but it just so happened that the
haunting episode that we did on Monday
was called demon Unearthed and then this
case that we're talking about on the
show tonight which one in the poll is
kind of usually called demon house
because that's what Zak Bagans yeah
vegans vegans not Vegas
that's how I'm gonna say it
um it's just just because no one else
does yeah but um but yeah so that was
his documentary about it it's sometimes
called I think on Wikipedia it's called
like the Ammons haunting or something
like that because that's the woman's
last name
but yeah so there was a little bit of
confusion about that but yeah we just
happened to do like two paranormal shows
this week that's all it was that's all
it was but uh so yeah hey everybody what
is uh what's going on they're talking
about armadillos yeah in the uh in the
in the comments there he said he'd seen
them on uh in Florida and Georgia but
now he saw them like uh someplace else
oh they're everywhere
yeah well they're scavengers
like deer butts yeah yeah I tell you I
can't I can't think of like armadillos
without thinking of like the deer
[__] people don't know what you're
talking about Jim they probably do
you've told that story more than once we
got new listeners I'm sure
even the old listeners even our old
listeners don't listen to every [__]
episode that's true all right
what she's talking about is uh I was
down in Mississippi visiting my dad
and I'd uh I was gonna go he's got
hunting rights on a certain piece of
property out there Masonite Masonite
Corporation logging territory he's
bought hunting rights on it so they had
a range set up out there whenever I got
new guns or worked up some new load that
I wanted to shoot you know I was loading
45 Auto and [__] 30 carbine and all
kinds of
yeah I was loading 25 auto that's how
[__] cool I was when I was a kid
before I joined the army look because it
was expensive and I had 25s but anyway
um
so I pack up something I was going to
shoot was probably at the time of 30
carbine
and had it it was heading out just like
seven miles my dad lives right there by
that land
seven miles to get to the land and I was
coming around a bend and I saw a dead
deer in the road
and I started to go around and it moved
I was like [__] I put the brakes on that
zombie deer yeah Is it alive I saw a
movie like that once an armadillo went
broke and ran out of its [__] yeah it
was inside of it in there he's chowing
down
yeah
right in the butt I was like what the
[__] so I'm going around the deer and
I'm looking and its ass was pretty big
because it had chewed it chewed some of
it I guess you're right at the exact
right time and place to see that well I
think it hurt I think it heard the car
coming don't you feel special I think it
hurt the car yeah
hurt I think I heard the car coming how
many people in the world can say that
they've seen an
armadillo's ass just you probably
deer came running out of him
and it was like shaking it off like oh
whoa man and they tried to run off the
road I think I thought it was going to
get run over yeah well they do get run
over well I mean I see live armadillos
sometimes but to be honest sadly uh you
mostly see dead ones like yeah as
roadkill on the side of the road
um Zach thank you very much giving us a
Super Chat yay an Indiana story leave it
to my home turf to create a city more
dangerous and abandoned than Detroit
that it appeared on Life After People
that was a great show yeah Gary yep I
lived in Detroit for and also the
hometown of Michael Jackson of all
[__] people yeah that's right yeah I
lived in Detroit for like 18 months man
Gary probably worse I had fun in Detroit
though a lot of good golf clubs
the shelter and [__] St Andrews Hall
and I think there was another one up
there called industry I think is what it
was called City Club
had a good time it's like something out
of The Crow
Yeah well yeah I mean that's where at an
apartment there was a converted
slaughterhouse I had the whole thing for
like 300 bucks yeah I could drive my
[__] 72 Lincoln Montego the
[__] was down rusted out I had
to spray painted it looked like a punk
Rider's car I could drive it into the
cattle elevator and then bring it up and
then park it into just this [__]
it's in my apartment but it was uh
that's pretty radical I don't know if
you parked your car yeah it was just
like a room that had like a
wash basins in it that was it it's just
concrete and then there was a bunch of
hallways of it zigzag none of the layout
made sense
because it had been turned into a bunch
of stuff over the years
and um like all the rooms were far apart
from each other and there was no way to
heat and cool it man it was [__]
terrible when winter came it was like
miserable
it's like sleeping outside
no way to heat it I had a little
electric heater and I'd [__] in a
sleeping bag inside the bed in the bed
and I just had a mattress I'd be in the
mattress underneath the covers inside a
sleeping bag
it's miserable you got to do what you
got to do yeah
but I got hard man
that sounded really dirty yeah oh yeah
burned my heart okay yeah not other
things going into the army a lot easier
you're like well at least I mostly won't
be freezing my ass off but then you
weren't freezing your ass off in Korea
though uh Bob Apple says hello fellow
peeps creeps got some punk rockers yeah
hey everybody what's everybody doing
I'm in a good mood tonight I don't know
why
[Laughter]
is that what it is
look at that little like like little
[__] Sinister look on your face it's
not Sinister man it's Friday we're gonna
have some stories to tell about working
on stream mate
yeah we'll tell those stories then no I
think yeah it's like we don't want to do
it too we want them here but it's like
yeah we have a whole we got a whole
story is we gotta hope for the shows
where the story is about streammate
well yeah it's it's been it's about what
I expected yeah but um it's yeah it's
just interesting like the I'm just gonna
say it's interesting the request that
you get yeah that's what I that's what
is fascinating yeah
working for all different kinds of
people who want to see all kinds of
weird [__]
oh come on
dude well yeah because that's the
have to do anything you don't want to do
I mean they can [__] off and find
somebody else it'll do that but it's
like yeah nobody asks for anything like
super super weird but it's a little odd
sometimes just sometimes like a little
bit odd yeah but yeah we can talk about
that all that happened is just jump in
and go anal
[__] want you to want you to do like
a whole goddamn full-length [__] porn
movie in five minutes yeah well because
you know because like I said that's what
that streaming platform you can't do
[__] for free like you know they have to
like buy time yeah they don't want to
buy the time right so they're trying to
like cheat and trying to get yeah this
and this and this and this and this but
I was like we can't do that like and I
mean yeah you'll get suspended well no
someone well not in the no you could you
can do all that everything they were
asking yeah no I'm just saying in the
free I said in the free no not for free
that's what I mean okay yeah you but I
was just saying dudes [__] talking
about something that take would take an
hour he wants to see it all in five
minutes go check out he's only paying
6.99 a minute yeah
okay thanks guys then
you're like [__] he's gone okay dude we
didn't get halfway down that list
it's like you gotta get some time damn
but yeah
all right probably not well I mean
that's the thing it's
you have to appreciate that you know and
I know we said we're going to talk about
this Friday but I'm just this is all I'm
going to say about it I said you do have
to appreciate that as much as free porn
as there is out there you have to
appreciate that there are people like
willing to pay for it yeah um you know
to pay you for it to do some things well
they try to get free [__] but they but
they also do try to get free [__] out of
you yeah like not everybody like some
people kind of know how it works and
they're just like yeah they they'll
immediately like pay for stuff but
[__] is asking for free samples
and [__] but yeah they're just kind of
like hey well just do it for a second
like and just I'm like no man we're not
doing that uh Ben said did you make
money a little bit yeah yeah we've only
we've only gone on a couple times
the first one was like three four hours
yeah and we only had three customers on
that one that was yeah what [__] 35
something like that the segment was only
about yeah we're only on for about an
hour and a half because that was like
last night and I was like tired got
about 25 bucks on it something like that
yeah but we don't have to act down yet I
mean you got to run this like a business
it takes time yeah we finally got the
videos uploaded and approved through
there they won't let me they won't let
us post a video with me in it they'll
let me stream but they won't let me
appear in anything yeah they have like a
weird I mean a weird legal problem like
I said we'll talk about it Friday but
it's like we figured out probably what
the Yeah legality of it is yeah because
they're very very careful about like
they said it'll probably change yeah
they said they're working on it like
it's in beta but yeah and I I don't
think it's a technical issue it's some
something legal it is yeah it has
something legal price something to do
with the production of pornographic
material yeah I think streaming is not
considered pornographic material
probably considered a communication
because it's private it's probably what
they're talking about so they don't have
the legal standing to sell it or the
licenses to sell it I wonder what they
do about stuff like Chaturbate then
where people just like do stuff on it
just it's not being recorded I guess
well
yeah you can record it I don't know we
can record it on our end and I'm sure
the other people they might have the
license
Tammy said is it because Tom is underage
I know look at look at that fresh face
boy I know man
I thought I'd just be kind of ignored no
man [__] are coming after me
too gotta watch them see that's what I'm
saying all right see you were trying to
tell me that it's like oh I'm just gonna
be all that I'm just gonna say in the
background everybody's gonna pay
attention to you it's like a lot of
people do but it's just like um it's
probably probably about half an hour
maybe I have dudes ask me questions and
[__] yeah how big is it okay
yeah yeah so it's like well you have to
think that since we're in the couple
section because that's a separate
section
um you're gonna get people that are
going in there like looking specifically
for that yeah so you're gonna get a lot
of people that are bi and stuff like
that so you know that's something that
we discovered because you know if they
just wanted to see like a solo female
there's like a there's a that's like 90
of the site is just women those girls
are busy they're good ones right
yeah they got Fitness chicks in there I
have to be bodybuilder girls in there
they got everything in there every now
every now we live in they got good
looking old women they got ugly old
women they got 18 year old girls in
there they got everything
actually we uh every now and then we see
one of our uh friends some of our
friends will see them in there yeah yeah
and I'm just like hey it's Pinky yeah
and this porn stars will be in we know
her Nina Hartley will be in there
working yeah I'm like man there's Nina
Hartley
fine you know well you know like I said
there's a lot of sites like this but
so a lot of them like uh see my friend's
wife in there yeah yeah yeah the guy
he's always yeah Amy Quinn I'm friends
yeah she was on the other day the other
day
all right so yeah let's go
let's start talking about excuse me
Jesus Christ very rude yeah
so let's start talking about this case
now you didn't know much about this case
to start with although me and you did
watch the Zach Bagans yeah documentary
about I'm sorry Zach I don't mean to
like pick on you and stuff like that but
it's just kind of like I get every time
I watch something about him like people
have a different pronunciation of his
name but when he said it himself in the
documentary he said Bagans so I'm
guessing that that's how he pronounces
it although like I said I don't know if
his family name is bag and then he's
like I'm not pronouncing it like that
because everyone's gonna call me Bilbo
and I'm not about that life so maybe
that's what it is I don't know but you
know if he pronounces it begins I'll
pronounce it pagans even though that
sounds like Bagels Zach Bagels that's
fine with that man's name
I feel bad like I said I'm being an
[__] today I'm sorry yeah
I'm just gonna call him Zach how about
that and then we'll just kind of like
skirt the whole issue but yeah so we did
watch the documentary because I was
curious about it I knew about this case
because I wrote about it for my book
um you know the Unseen hand a couple
years ago but and I knew like when I was
writing the book when did what the [__]
did that book come out 2017 2018 and I
think that when I wrote the book
um Zach had just bought the house
um or had just demolished the house
spoiler alert
um but the documentary hadn't come out
yet because I remember like being like
Oh I wonder if that documentary is ever
going to come out like checking on it so
I don't think the documentary came out
until after the book came out so I was
like really curious to watch it if you
have Amazon Prime it's on there that's
where we watched it
um
it's kind of interesting he does
actually interview a lot of people
having to do with the case like a lot of
the witnesses like the cops and [__]
like that
um and he does stay in the house and
there's Shenanigans we'll talk about
that later but
I don't know I I kind of feel like I
don't know maybe we'll get into that
later like how I kind of feel about it's
a pretty good documentary like I don't
believe any of that Ghost Adventures
[__] you know what I mean and I don't
really like that show
um because it's boring but I will say
that the documentary was at least not
all that boring I mean at least it was
usually something going on it wasn't
just a bunch of people walking around
and you know uh low light cameras going
did you hear that you know what I mean
it wasn't for like an hour at least like
[__] happened and he did like interview
people and stuff so it was it was pretty
entertaining even though I think it's
largely [__] but you know
um so yeah
so let's talk about
this haunting case
so this is actually fairly recent I
guess at least compared to a lot of the
other cases that we talk about and the
and the Witnesses are all still alive
and have access to them testimony yeah
it goes across the board
uh what was a police captain he saw some
[__]
some uh social workers saw some stuff
with the kids saw the kid run up the
wall backwards all kinds of weird [__]
so
there are some
some witnesses that have some weight to
the testimony of the people I think were
bullshitting they wanted money
I'm not gonna give the you know I'm not
going to give you testimony until you
pay me that kind of [__]
but it is interesting case just because
we have more than one witness we have
multiple Witnesses
yeah
and um
The credibility is I would say is kind
of okay
okay yeah
I will note though I was listening to a
pot into a really good podcast about
this actually it was a guy and a girl
and they are very skeptical
and so they were kind of saying well you
have to think too that even
um some of the cops and stuff like that
that you know said that they saw
specific things and everything
um admitted that they already believed
in demons or were already you know what
I mean so they might have been primed to
kind of like see things in that
framework maybe well okay these are um
African-Americans all right and they
tend to have Christian backgrounds so
just right there they're going to
believe in demons and angels and ghosts
and Jesus and God you know that's just
part of the culture
so yeah they already it's whether or not
they saw something I think they did they
were scared yeah just freaked them out
was was there testimony accurate
I think they read into some of the stuff
that they saw
I think they were spooked enough to wear
their imagination ran away with them
but I also think they saw some stuff
yeah uh just I think
well we'll get into it we'll get into it
Bob Apple said if anyone remembers
Paranormal State that show was better
edited and got straight to the good [__]
not nearly as boring I don't think I
ever saw that but um I've heard of it
but I don't think I've ever seen it I
saw it it was a it was a fun series to
watch I think mostly [__]
but that doesn't preclude like my
enjoyment of it yeah yeah because I
watch horror movies and those are like
obviously not real the two guys that
read it were it turned out they were
kind of uh
on men type you know they stole some
money and [__] and [__]
because they were gonna hit when they
lost the show they were going to have
this big seminar and people were gonna
pay a bunch of money and collected a
bunch of money from their fans to do
some kind of like a seminar type dealer
right and they like a skip engine or
something like a convention and they
skipped out on the money took it
[__] yeah
[Music]
um
making [__] wild posts about handle
bleaching and [__] like that so it's
just he just had that was just a weird
[__] with those dudes right so I don't
know how credible
those guys were well I well the thing
about it like I said all those
paranormal shows none of them are
particularly incredible to be honest
with you um they're just like for
entertainment so like I said if I'm
gonna watch one for entertainment
purposes at least entertain me I don't
like I said I don't want to watch one
that's just like 48 minutes of
douchebags like walking around a dark
building yeah pretending they heard
stuff or it's like something touch me
you know what I mean I'm just like just
stop it like have something exciting
even if you have to fake it make
something exciting happen uh Emily says
totally unrelated but oh my God I love
the fact that Jenny is matching her hair
with the lipstick and the top stunning
yeah I did it I did an all red today
yeah sure sure I did it all red Ensemble
yeah that's her right there there's my
red Ensemble today yeah
I don't know why I guess because I did
blue last night I guess for the other
for the other
show
the other show you got compliments on
the blue hair there too yeah
well the blue is my favorite like I said
yes
I've heard from across the [__]
planet all the way down as far as Saudi
Arabia osada's like she looks best with
the blue hair yeah yeah I think so too
it makes you look pale
unless you're in a good way and we like
that yeah you look real pale like I said
I think that that's it matches best with
my skin yeah I'm a cool person you know
what I mean but the Red's nice too and
like I said red is more like my natural
and she is pale she's got beautiful skin
thank you
this is it's actually like one of my one
of my better features actually like I
always had really nice yeah there's no
even skin I don't even yeah yeah and I
don't have I never had like any bad
blemishes or anything like no Readiness
even when I was a teenager no ruddiness
or anything she kind of got some sexy
ass veins and [__] in certain places
sexy ass face yeah
blue hot blue veins yeah blue veins well
you never told me that before this is a
new I'm down here I'd be busy at the
time
you said I was too busy to tell you yeah
too busy how sexy your Titans are
oh you're so silly that is very nice
though that's it's a very specific
compliment I'll take it I'll take it but
you know it's not it's not often you
have people tell you that your veins are
nice but I never really thought about it
but I appreciate it
so yeah so there's [__] here
happened in Gary Indiana
and apparently the the shenanigans began
in November of 2011. so like I said not
too long ago now the Ammons family which
was Latoya Ammons uh shoots the mom and
then her mom whose name is Rosa Campbell
and then Latoya had three kids I think
they were um one of them was I think she
had two boys and a girl I think they
were seven nine and twelve I think if
I'm remembering correctly
so they move into this house and they
were renting it and it was just kind of
it's not there anymore but there's
pictures of it all over the um all over
the Internet it's just like a regular
kind of old
sort of like dumpy looking house like
you'd see in Gary Indiana that was
probably built in what the 40s 50s
something like that
so they move in now the first thing that
they noticed probably about a month
after
renting the house
was the front of the house had this kind
of um like a screened in porch type
situation
and they noticed all these big black
flies again shades of Amityville Horror
some I saw one thing that said
horseflies but I don't that's a
different thing so I don't know if we're
just talking about like just big fat
house flies or horse flies because horse
flies are pretty big but you say look
there was a bunch of them in the screen
and porch
and they thought this was very weird
because you know it's Indiana and it's
winter time like you know winter time is
coming it's very very cold and usually
uh you don't get your house getting
filled up with flies in the wintertime
in Indiana
that's what I'm saying so they thought
it was very unusual and they said today
we go in there and there'd be swarms of
them in there and then they would you
know kill them all they'd spray them
with poison or whatever and then like
the next day there'd be like a [__] time
I'm back again so like I said very much
like the Amityville Horror type thing
was like the first thing that they
noticed
the next thing they notice evidently was
um Latoya and Rosa started to hear
footsteps like real heavy kind of boot
footsteps
on the basement stairs
like kind of just going up and down
and sometimes the door that went from
the basement to the kitchen would like
Creak open by itself and they're like
and even when they locked the door like
going they would still hear the
footsteps and [__] like that so that was
like
um creeping them out obviously we got
somebody named half naked you half naked
you she said she it was empty when she
drove by she said she must be talking
about this house yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah because
um yeah it was empty lot when I drew by
the abandoned church was far more
interesting yeah it's uh it's an empty
lot because Zach Bagans Bagans
um he had it demolished at the in uh
2016 I want to say like after he was
done with his documentary he had it
demolished and they showed that it was
in a documentary too and I have some
theories about why he did that
I know what his theory is about it but
um I have my own theory about why I did
it I'm just saying so that's why the
house isn't there anymore
so yeah so they hear footsteps [__] like
that uh doors opening by themselves
flies
now Rosa who's like the grandma
she said that she woke up one night and
there was like a man like a shadow man
type of thing figure walking back and
forth in the living room like pacing
back and forth
and I don't know if he like disappeared
later or what but then like when they
went out there like to see what was
going on with it there was like wet boot
prints all over the floor
so I don't know if this was a real
person or they were trying they were
trying to imply that it was like a
shadow person but he was still leaving
wet blueprints on there who knew that
demons were boots not me yeah
I don't think they saw a real person
probably I mean somebody just although
it would be weird for somebody to just
break in your house and then just Pace
back and forth I'm not you know I'm not
trying to like say it was a demon or
nothing I'm just saying that's not the
first thing
that's what I yeah they might have been
like living in the [__] business I've
got to get out of here yeah boom man
somebody like lives they're coming yeah
yeah I mean yeah it could totally could
have been
so so this kind of [__] goes on for a
couple months like I said then it's
March of 2012.
now the whole family it's two o'clock in
the morning but the whole family are
awake because uh they'd had like a loved
one or relative or something like that
who had died and they had been to the
funeral and the wake and everything like
that so everyone was kind of still up
because they were like still upset about
it
now Latoya was in her mom's room
and uh also like one of the girls like
one of the daughters was in there and
[__] like that
and then basically what happened like
somebody yelled and then they ran into
the 12 year old daughter's room
and she was allegedly
levitating over the bed
uh and they said they all saw this
so all of them you know proceed to
surround the bed and start praying and
[__] like that and the girl like gently
falls back onto the bed from being
floating up in the air
now when they woke her up she didn't
have any memory of what had happened
so uh whoever though because they had
some friends over that night too because
like I said there'd been a funeral and
stuff like that and those people were
like yep wouldn't open the [__] out we
just don't want any more to do with that
so apparently they never returned
so at this point you know Latoya and her
mom are like okay well we don't know
exactly what the hell is going on in
here but it's obviously paranormal and
it's probably not good
so they decided they were gonna contact
the church
so they call a bunch of local churches
[__] like that but apparently like no
one really wanted to help them or didn't
believe them or whatever so was there
was that
now one uh Church person did say okay
well
I'll you know just pray for you or
whatever and then kind of call them back
and said oh your house is just like full
of demons so you know I'm just like gee
thanks that's that's a big help
now also this person told them well what
you should do is cleanse the home and
here's the funny thing they didn't
actually mean because you know on a
haunting where they always say you have
to do a cleansing and it's like with all
the sage and [__] they actually wanted
them to like really cleanse the home
with like bleach and ammonia and [__]
you know what I mean so she's like yeah
your house is filthy it's like that's
that attracts demons everybody knows
that but um yeah I don't know so I guess
bleach and ammonia also gets rid of
demons so again or whatever
yeah it does
Spock is a little too far over okay
there you go yeah
the light keeps changing yeah if there's
a light over here that keeps like
changing color it went back to the
supposed normal that's the normal color
but every now and then it'll just flash
a different color for no reason at all
ghost yeah I guess so that's those
demons that's all they can do let's just
change the light color every now and
then just get on my nerves
so yeah so they plead the house with
bleach and ammonia and then they're
supposed to draw crosses on all the
doors and windows with oil presumably
olive oil I don't know
I haven't been visited probably using
corn oil yeah olive oil is expensive
yeah
the vegetable I could use vegetable yeah
did you just get that peanut peanut and
what's that what's the other one if I
can uh how are you talking about
peanut was expensive and then
sunflower castor oil what's the [__]
other one that they uh
I bought it a few times
um oh I know I know what you're talking
about supposed to be a healthier
alternative
doesn't matter did I say sunflower oil
it's not something yeah
Zach says corn is our state's number one
export yeah so yeah it's probably just
all
corn oil
does that work or does it have to be
olive oil
ghost probably don't care that's what
I'm thinking probably not ghosts
wouldn't want you to spend all that
money
yeah you thought of it yeah
yeah [__]
[Laughter]
so they go around with the oil and they
do the crosses and why not
also
um put crosses on the kids foreheads and
pour an oil on their feet and hands and
everything like that like you do and I'm
pretty sure that that was olive oil not
the extra virgin [__] probably like I
said go to the dollar store and get that
cheap [__]
now so then
um they decided they're gonna like get
some extra help so they go consult a
couple of Psychics which you know that's
probably usually never a good idea
so the psychics come out and do like
kind of an assessment and they tell that
you're gonna laugh they tell the Ammons
family
that the house is home to
guess how many demons 200.
200 yeah I mean it's [__] crowded up
with demons in there they must be just
shoulder to shoulder because this isn't
a big house right
so there's 200 demons and they can't do
much of anything
yeah if there's 200 demons in your house
and all they can do is like make a door
Creak and yeah throw some flies around
and [__] like that I'm like specially
when in the stories
just one angel can [__] wipe out an
entire city
yeah I mean don't give demons any ideas
and they just kind of gone chill they
just kind of [__] around yeah maybe
they're just really lazy yeah they make
flies happen and [__] leave [__]
Footprints I mean demons they basically
are just like yeah leave some wet boot
Prince and I'm tired I'm just gonna get
some beer out of the fridge and just lay
here and watch Ghost Adventures there's
this uh there's this habit of blaming
anything that's scary or paranormal on
demons I think demons would be way at
the bottom of the list
yeah uh and I mean I honestly I really
don't think demons even exist
um so and if they did like I said they
wouldn't be doing pulling little
[__] like this even in
the New Testament there's um
um
confusion or you know uh I wouldn't say
they're two different opinions they say
demons and sometimes they're talking
about
punished angels and other times we're
talking about Eve The Souls of Evil Dead
you know what I mean but you never
really can't tell what it is they're
talking like for instance uh in that one
story where Jesus casts out all the
demons and makes them go into the pigs
they're talking about the spirits of the
evil dead now that I'm talking about
Angelic demons
so there's more than one kind of demon
evidently
just any kind of evil spirit probably
would to the ancient Roman Christians
were just a demon yeah I mean any any
paranormal uh being that's doing [__]
you don't like I guess it's like a demon
if you didn't like it it scared you it
was a demon
so yeah 200 demons which I don't know
that's just very funny to me
so um basically I mean Latoya and her
mom were just kind of like yeah that
totally tracks with all the [__] that's
been going on in here
now the psychics very unhealthily uh
told Latoya and her family to move
um they're like
uh or broke ass does this you know
obviously you can't [__] I love the
way they just say oh we'll just move
like with what move into a refrigerator
box that's what it's gonna end up yeah
like poor people can just move that's
what I mean it's like you gotta save up
for years you know how expensive moving
is she's Christ just move to move where
that's why ghettos exist they can't
afford to get out of them that's right
every dude I knew that lived in them was
trying to get out yeah
I'm hanging out their brother said I
finally made it out of that [__]
right yeah that's just like a damn
quicksand it is once you're in there
there's no you can't get out you can't
get out right yeah that's what I'm
saying so it's like trap it's it is just
very glib for somebody to say oh we'll
just move if your shit's haunted it's
like like I said move to where I'm gonna
have to live in my car yeah you know
so yeah
so um what you so what The Clairvoyant
said she's like well obviously you know
I'm broke dick I can't move
so the psychic's like okay well
consolation prize here's what you do you
set up an altar in your basement because
I guess that was where most of the
activity was that's where the footprints
were and [__] like that
so basically she sets up an altar down
there which is just like they had like a
side table or something put a white
sheet over it put some white candles on
it they had like some statues of like
Jesus and Mary and Joseph and all that
put all that [__] on there and then and
then they did like her and the kids kept
like they put white shirts on and
scarves and stuff and then they started
burning sage and reading from the Bible
and all that kind of stuff like trying
to drive all these 200 demons out
so they did all this
and apparently the Paranormal Activity
stopped for three days this is just like
a haunting it'll stop for a couple days
and then it comes back worse and that's
exactly what happened in this situation
so after the three days had passed the
demons however many of them there are
apparently began to Target the children
now so the kids started acting real
weird like they started talking in like
super growly voices like doing these
creepy evil Smiles they would like fight
with each other all the time which they
hadn't done previously I'm assuming
um you know their eyes would bug out
they were just like started acting like
really [__]
weird
the hilarious thing about this is that
so they start to believe the kids are
possessed by the demons now Rosa the
grandma she says well luckily for me I
was born with demon immunity that's not
what she said but she said that she um
was born with special protection from
Evil which essentially is like demon
immunity she got demon vaccination so
they can't get her
um but Latoya apparently
felt some kind of possessive action as
well like she said that sometimes she
would feel like really lightheaded like
she was gonna faint or she'd start
getting really hot or her whole body
would start shaking like she couldn't
control her limbs anymore and stuff like
that so it's kind of like she's getting
residual
demon possession I'm kind of leaking
over her I guess like from the kids
so another thing that happened was the
youngest kid who was seven
would um sit in their closet and they
would talk to
essentially An Invisible Boy
and apparently according to this kid
this boy ghost boy told him what it felt
like to be murdered
um the seven-year-old also evidently
kind of got thrown around the house like
he'd come like flying out of the
bathroom like hit the wall and [__] like
that
um at least according to the family
um also the oldest kid who was 12 uh
kind of went flying and like hit a
headboard or something had to get
stitches in their head yeah if you go
fly to hit headboards all the time
that's that's true
I love I love your little like your
little dirty outside it's just like so
funny yeah sometimes I don't even know
I'm walking into it but I'm always
walking into it because you can always
you can kind of spin anything
[Laughter]
brace yourself woman
well that's it all I'm saying is it's a
good thing that the headboard is like
you can like hang on to it you know what
I mean it's not solid it's like it's
like
slacks you know what I mean not slats
but yeah like rungs yeah so it's like
that so you can hang on to it if you
need to I mean sometimes you need to
you'll get a picture of it
you're gonna stream from there we should
we should probably like set up some
lights yeah
people are like what the [__]
jeffreyard said kids behaving badly and
fighting so basically like normal kids
yeah yeah I mean that's well no the way
it was portrayed in the in the
documentary is uh pretty over the
[__] top but I don't know if we don't
know
more like demonic attacks and they're
getting like their eyes could roll all
the way back and they're like like that
you know what I mean like some from
Trilogy of Terror yeah it was like yeah
it was like super zoomy dolls yeah
they're [__] attacking you and [__]
yeah
so uh so yeah also
um the daughter also said that sometimes
she felt like somebody was holding her
down and choking her yeah
um and that she heard disembodied voices
telling her that she was gonna die and
that she'd never see her family again
and stuff like that now before you go
any further okay uh let's go ahead and
talk a little bit about the documentary
that we saw yeah okay
the actual reenactments were pretty cool
they were it was a pretty it's a pretty
good movie
um
and uh the acting from the little kids
and the people that were supposed to
represent the family members and all the
[__] uh uh social workers and
everything I thought it was good
it was you kind of like it was pretty
but the kids were acting like they were
demonically possessed and I'm like okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah like I said the eyes
rolling back and [__] like that and
they're like speaking in tongues yeah
they're little kids they're little kids
but they look cool yeah it did actually
um Jeff yard said with all the high
drinks my siblings and I did in our use
we could have explained it all as
demonic possession and call up the
Warrens for a book deal yeah see if
you'd have like thought about it you
totally could have got in on that action
Zach says so at what point do you guys
buy a reinforced bed frame
I do too actually we kind of like
inherited it yeah we threw our [__]
Posturepedic mattress bed away because
it was just [__] starting all the
wood and it was starting to warp and
everything and it was old the air
mattresses started to leak yeah
periodically and I had to go in there
and put patches in them and that was a
several thousand dollar bed yeah but it
was just old though 20 something years
ago
yeah maybe we'll close to 30 years old
probably [__] 20 something years old
We inherited that one too right so what
through that one away and was used one
that we used to have as like a guest bed
right but that was something we picked
up cheap right and we had guests over
but now we're sleeping on that yeah it's
not that it's not terrible but it's just
not it's not super it's not a real good
one yeah I have to say it's not super
comfortable and you see uh there are
things in this world called bad
gangsters
[Laughter]
let's go out and buy a [__] bed it's
like you're gonna go talk to these
gangsters to get in bed
I got these special [__] places to go
and they're trying to [__] well this
model isn't it's like it's like you
buying a casket or some [__] like that
all these different [__] things they
make a big commission off of them I just
want a [__] bed well now you can
order them like online you can get ones
that are all like rolled up in a box
yeah like from uh what was that one that
um
I saw a commercial for one the other day
that had something like that I think
they're expensive but they're supposed
to be like right a good man really
expensive it is yeah and like I said it
just comes in like a box about yay big
and then it just goes and it like pops
it just like that like I said
um
can't access oh hell yeah tornadoes are
hitting us hard holy [__] really
go out there and go yell out grab a
Bible go out the front door the power of
Christ compels you just keep [__] I
mean don't do that you'll get blown away
it says uh but yeah he said tornadoes
are hitting us hard we needed y'all
tonight I love you Tom and Jenny from
planet cat we love you too who said that
can neck from Pat and Cat okay please
don't get blown away all right it's Pat
yeah what's up Pat we get tornadoes down
here a lot too and they're very very
scary you two need to come see us on
stream mate hey we'll go cam to cam all
four yeah I'm not sure you're a cute
girlfriend well um when we're streaming
I mean we'll definitely be streaming
Saturday night yeah I don't know about
um we gotta get [__] [__] right first
though find the best ways to do stuff
it's not really it's not really time to
[__] with us yet yeah we're still
learning the ropes yeah I don't even
know how a lot of the [__] works on yeah
we don't even know how to use all the
[__] program stuff yet we're just
kind of like feeling around yeah dudes
what the [__] does this do dudes are
paying us [__] money for private
sessions and it's on and we don't even
know it
real quick
using mental powers to rock up
that's what I'm gonna start calling you
Tom yeah this is [__] terrible that's
like pretty funny
yeah Ben says lots of views LOL yeah
pretty much
um so yeah where were we okay
so at this point
um DCS is involved Department of Child
Services right DPS Department of Public
Safety no DCS oh DCS okay don't try to
be don't try to be clever I said DCS
okay I thought you said DP no I did it
uh what does one search for on
streammate to locate y'all just go in
there and look for couples yeah we're
under couples and I think we're just
under tomgen 13. yeah or Jameson 13 or
something if we're not online just look
after you search for couples go to
[__] uh offline and just scroll down
you can't whatever picture we took last
probably heard a blue wig you'll see us
yeah
I don't remember if they put up the last
one that like the last one you did last
time you streamed or if they just put up
the generic one that we have up there
right where I also have blue but yeah
and if you're a member you got to give
credit card you become a member you'll
be able to interact
you'll also be able to go on our profile
there
and buy videos
the videos range from probably about two
dollars to about fifteen dollars
depending on how long they are
and for now it's just Jin
wasn't able to put the ones where we
worked where we were performing together
because they were good
yeah we did it yeah we did it real good
we're gonna find another platform in the
meantime
probably something like
minivids or
um
what's the other one clips for sale
something like that
yeah because we made we made so many
good ones and I was like man I really
want to put like those on a platform
only fans is [__] hard to get in
yeah I already have a family account I
applied for one but it takes a lot it's
a long time and then once we have fans
they we can tag each other and we can
put them up there we can put them up
there fastly is uh kind of in some ways
better than only fans because they take
less
yeah they take a percentage Yeah because
I don't know if you know but stream
eight takes a massive yeah streaming
takes 60 65 65 65 you only get one third
of what you make yeah
so you gotta but they're good about um
they're real good quality control for
clients yeah nobody [__] around or is
it you can't really troll there you'll
get nobody wants to get kicked off the
platform yeah
so yeah like everybody was pretty like
straightforward yeah respectful like
nobody is just coming in there [__]
with you telling you like how ugly yeah
man you fat you know because if they do
that kind of [__] they'll get they'll
get de-platformed right yeah they'll get
kicked up yeah and these pervs they're
in their regular regular you know I mean
they're [__] in there working them
girls yeah so
they don't want to get kicked off yeah
and then uh
um I was gonna say
[__] only fans takes a lot from you
that's not a great platform really
fansley is a lot more forgiving in terms
of [__] they'd take less from you and
they're not real Ultra paranoid about
your content so they're a little more
like it's hard to even get properly id'd
on only fans you hear these people like
well I'll just quit my job and [__]
make get on only yeah good luck
good [__] love getting on only fans
is kind of like is the modern day
equivalent of getting on a TV sitcom I
mean we just gave up I just gave up you
just can't get on because they say well
the photo quality is not good enough
okay well this isn't quite the ID that
we want oh you have to have more social
media presence they just keep yeah they
keep coming up with like an excuse not
to let you on right but the thing about
it is there's lots of other options like
you don't really and and like I said
once we get all of our other [__]
established maybe we'll go over there
and put some [__] on but yeah they don't
want to they don't like to take in new
people
I think they want people that are
already on other platforms that way if
if you do anything wrong on there they
got legal protection say well these
other
these other platforms [__] okay their
IDs and their their materials so you
know what I mean we're not the outlier
right
they're scared of what you're gonna do
on there yeah and only fast was not
originally supposed to be things for
adult content that was supposed to be
for other [__] right it's just that
adult content took over right it came
its main well and then they tried to ban
it for a little while and then everybody
flipped out like um that's kind of the
whole point of it now and they were like
yeah you're right so they were back on
it and fansley is for adult content yeah
that's what it was that's what it's made
for made for for them so you can get
approved in a day or two oh no no
actually it took a couple weeks it takes
a couple weeks but they usually approve
you the first time
if you give them what they want what
they ask for and I didn't really give
them what they asked for they told me to
make a video of myself holding a piece
of paper saying a certain thing I didn't
quite say what I and they were like
whatever
that was supposed to say the date too oh
yeah I didn't say the date yeah
well like I said it's just it's
obviously it's obvious that you're not
under 18. see obviously you're not
underage so they're not going to worry
too much about it the only fans are just
going to look for any excuse to get rid
of you
they don't want you on there
well like I said they have enough people
on there and it's just kind of like
they're gonna and like I said they don't
want to get sued it's just like like any
adult site you know some of them are
more stringent than others but none of
them want to get in trouble and then
another thing is is that on of her only
fans
they know they're demographic they know
their customer they know who makes money
and who does it so what they're looking
for is mostly really young girls really
hot
um uh really hot [__] uh cougars and
girls with extremely large breasts
you'll get right in yeah if you're
anything kind of outside of that they're
like uh you're gonna take up space on
our platform they're all they want to
Target just for a certain type
if you ask me then they got cooking
shows on there so go tell them go you
know
you go figure Jeff here and said my
friend uses just for fans he loves it
and they are specific for lgbtq sex
workers yeah yeah there's lots of that's
what I mean it's like only fans is the
most popular one that's the one with the
name recognition but there's lots and
lots and lots of other options like if
you want to go that route stuff for gay
stuff that's usually its own site and
you're better to go on a gay specific
site for that
because that's where they're all going
yeah
that's true this is your target
marketing yeah
but like I said there's ones out there
for everybody yeah so fancy is kind of
in the middle yeah it's kind of a more
generic it's I think it's the second
most popular in it like after at least
as far as like the only fans type
similar thing and notice what what does
well on fancy is things like
spicy
uh cosplay girls
yeah and gender bending cosplay girls uh
[__] uh that that's real popular on
fansley
yeah it's just you know that's just
where they're all culminating
and they're kind of The Oddities they're
the ones that kind of had a little
couldn't really get on only fans because
they're they're they're not really
mainstream only if that's mainstream
[__] yeah
okay do you want to get back to the
store all right so we took a quick break
oh um you guys go ahead and hit the like
button if you can't help us out
uh how long we've been streaming
54 minutes okay it's almost time to do
commercials actually I'm not even
halfway through halfway through okay no
that's okay that's what I mean
all right so um at this point DCS is
involved because I believe that
um a neighbor reported that there was
possibly allegedly
perhaps abuse going on in the home
so DCS becomes involved at this point
now the Ammons family they had their own
uh physician whose name was uh who I'm I
always have trouble pronouncing his last
name it's Dr
um on on you cool I think is how you
pronounce his last name
and so he comes out to the house at
their request
now when he comes out there uh the two
sons basically start doing like some
extras and [__] they're like you know
talking to growly voices and cursing and
blah blah
now some of the people that were in the
house for this uh you know kind of
wellness check or whatever it was also
claimed that they saw the youngest son
who was seven
um kind of like levitating in the air so
there was that
oh and he kind of got thrown into the
wall also
and I guess like the two boys
you know all this [__] was going on and
they ended up like just passing out like
losing Consciousness right
and they tried to wake them up and they
couldn't wake them up so the doctor uh
called 9-1-1 and a bunch of ambulances
came and cops and stuff like that so
they took the boys to the hospital
now so Latoya follows them to the
hospital obviously and she's kind of
trying to put olive oil on him and [__]
like that because like I said she thinks
they're possessed evidently
um and apparently everyone just thought
that was like really funny like what the
[__] is she doing
now
um so the one kid the middle kid the
nine-year-old
he wakes up uh in the hospital and he's
acting normal again but the youngest one
the seven-year-old when they woke up
when he woke up he was like thrashing
around and screaming and [__] like that
and according to witness reports it took
five grown men to hold him down this is
seven-year-old boy
apparently
so like I said DCs are involved at this
point
um the neighbor who reported them who
obviously remained Anonymous said that
they suspected that Latoya might have
some kind of mental illness and that the
kids were quote unquote performing for
her or that they or that she was
encouraging them to act this way
so they actually ended up through the
auspices of DCs they actually ended up
doing a psychological evaluation of
Latoya herself uh and they could not
find any sign of uh mental illness of
any kind evidently
now they had a case manager from DCS her
name was Valerie Washington
now she came in and uh you know assessed
the situation and examined the kids and
stuff like that um all the kids seem to
be uh in good health they didn't seem to
have any injuries or anything like that
that would suggest that they were being
abused uh or anything like that
now
the the DCS lady Valerie Washington she
also interviewed the children
uh the seven-year-old uh basically
growled at her and like bared his teeth
at her and was you know his eyes rolled
back in his head and [__] like that and
then he turned on his nine-year-old
brother and started strangling him
um and they had to pry the kid off
so there's that and then so this kind of
went on for a few hours there was like
another nurse there uh whose name was
Willie Walker and he said that he saw
some of this stuff as well that like the
kid was acting all crazy and like trying
to strangle the brother and all this
other kind of [__] and then the
seven-year-old said to the nine-year-old
uh growled at him it's time to die I
will kill you like he said to the other
kid and I'm just like okay that's pretty
[__] up
and then the nine-year-old starts
head-butting the grandma now I think
this is still at the hospital to be
honest I don't think this is back at the
house
so the grandma
is trying to like
get the demon out or whatever and I
think she started saying something like
saying something to him like you know
you're you are not you or something like
that she was saying to him here's not
here yeah so she like grabs both his
hands and she's like praying and stuff
like that and apparently this is the
kind of the craziest
um one of the craziest things in this
[__] thing and I kind of wish I'd
been there or I kind of wish somebody
had because this was 2011 2012. they had
cell phones they had smartphones
um I don't know why nobody videotaped
this because that would have been really
good
um but apparently what happened then
was that while Rosa the Grandma had the
kids hands in her hands and was praying
the kid walked backwards up the wall of
this hot of this little hospital room
and went up on the ceiling and then
flipped over his grandma's head and
landed on his feet like on the other
side of her
apparently uh this is what happened and
apparently this was witnessed by a nurse
that was in the room and also by Valerie
Washington it was the caseworker uh she
noped the [__] out of the room because
she's like yeah I don't want any part of
this and like [__] took off I think
the nurse also took off to be honest
with you like after after they saw that
um yeah so they did that now they go to
get they run and get the doctor and be
like you know you would not believe this
[__] like what this kid just did like
they explained it to him and then the
doctor came back in the room and was
like okay well did you just you know
walk up the wall backwards or whatever
and the kid said I don't know what
you're talking about like he acted like
he couldn't remember and then he told
him to do it again and the kid's like
what are you talking about I can't do
that you know what I mean so that was
that whole thing like I said I don't
know I wasn't there nobody
filmed it on their phone
um which probably they should have but
it sounds weird but I just you know I
don't really know
what exactly maybe it wasn't like as
dramatic as like they made it sound you
know what I'm saying yeah
so at this point
um
the DCS is like okay well we don't have
a court order
to get these kids out of the house but
we're gonna get one so they applied for
a court order because they said
obviously something is not right is like
going on in here and they thought for
the kids protection that they would take
them into DCS custody until they got a
court order so they actually took her
kids
took all of them away
so what happened then was that the
chaplain at the hospital
calls up this uh uh Reverend Reverend
Michael I guess Maginot is how you would
pronounce his last name
um yeah yeah no yeah it looks like a
French yes it's real common name in
Louisiana that's yeah down in New
Orleans that's what I figured imagine
though so they call him up
and the hospital chaplain weirdly I mean
this is Indiana I guess it's kind of
like a real religious area a real
religious community so the hospital
chaplain says um
calls up the Reverend and says you
should perform an exorcism
on the nine-year-old because he just
walked up a [__] wall
Reverend is like well okay
um I I gotta like do some research first
I can't just jump right into exorcism
right you have to go and do like all the
interviews and figure out if it's not
mental illness or you know do you can't
just do exorcisms willy-nilly no matter
what a haunting would have you believe
so um so basically what happened so I
guess they brought majino back to the
house
and they told him about everything that
had been going on
this was kind of funny to me too so
they're like so while he's in the house
and they're talking to him he's like
every time he would go like down the
hall like toward where the bathroom was
like the light in the bathroom would
begin to flicker you know what I mean
but then when he would get close to it
like it would stop flickering and his
explanation was oh well that's the demon
doing that and it stops flickering
because it's scared of me I wish I
thought it was like really kind of funny
I don't know if he said it exactly like
that but I'm like
like again like the demon is just making
a light flicker which
you know all you have to do is like
loosen up the bulb and it'll do that so
it's like really not that impressive
lights would flicker it mammoth
sometimes we catch it we'd look at the
damn light switch and see if the light
switch was moving up and down uh usually
it didn't although I did see it move up
and down but not not when it flickered
when it's when it turned [__] off it did
it by the light bulb
that it usually just does it by
interrupting the damn current somehow
cause a light bulb to flicker I've seen
it
yeah that's probably how he probably how
it was done here see this is the thing I
think this is Poltergeist because it
starts off the kids
told you guys a lot of time it starts
off with kids and and the symptoms kind
of look like what you would call
possession
it's not though it's the kids it's in a
fugue
and there's a recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis happening we'll get into
that later
Ben says believing your children are
demon possessed doesn't count as mental
illness anymore yeah that's kind of
where my head was at also I'm just kind
of like that that does seem kind of
weird that you can say that in all
seriousness and people are like oh yeah
she's fine
you know what I mean but okay
well
the DCS workers saw some phenomenon
so
or have they seen it so yeah at this
point she saw yeah yeah she was in the
hospital room they knew something was
going on because remember they on the on
the Zach documentary they interviewed
her see it sounds crazy but I've seen
this kind of stuff before I was involved
in it
this kind of stuff does happen it's just
that the story around I believe this is
just a a decent Poltergeist case
Poltergeist isn't ghost it's recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis comes out of
kids
it does look like possession
sometimes mine didn't too much but in
other cases it did
and adults can't handle it
there's a lot of Witnesses in my case we
wrote a book about it
adults can't handle it they don't know
exactly what to do
and um if something like a poltergeist
is going down and you in a DCS worker
saw the phenomenon and then somebody
says I think this kid's possessed they
would go yeah some weird shit's going on
you know they're gonna throw you in
prison and call you crazy for that
they're just going to try to sweep it
under the rug like yeah let's just not
say anything you know I guarantee you
those those people didn't say anything
at that time they didn't tell their
bosses yeah they just let it ride
because their bosses wouldn't believe
them
we didn't call the cops yeah we thought
what would happen if we called the cops
they'd show up and the phenomena was
stop and then the cops would think we
were crazy
because that's because the Poltergeist
was kind of cruel that way
so we didn't say we didn't tell anybody
Samantha later Samantha said is this the
house
Zach Biggins bought and knocked down yes
it is yes it is yeah so we're talking
about today that's not saying much
though this house wasn't worth anything
yeah he bought it for 35 Grand yeah and
then you could knock it down it wouldn't
be anything well and like I said when we
talk about the documentary a little bit
I kind of want to get into my 35
thousands nothing although so in Detroit
you could buy a house for a dollar
I don't know you used to be able to the
problem was you had to have it rebuild
it you had to put money in it to get it
up to code within a certain time well
yeah definitely hundreds of thousands
that's true and you're in the middle of
a [__] guy you're in the middle of a
[__] apocalypse
[__] whole place fall apart so no one
did so no one would buy no one bought
them no right because why would you yeah
it would be Financial suicide yeah
unless you had like a [__] ton of money
you just want to do it for shits and
giggles you'd have to buy the whole
block right because every [__] house
on the damn block was just a [__]
wreck you know crack house just no
windows all busted out roofs caving in
and [__] yeah
so yeah okay so magino
that's like the magino line I just
thought yeah
so imagine a line is over without me now
I'm gonna call him that
so he's at the house like I said
interviewing uh Rosa and LA choya and uh
you know like I said light's flickering
and he's like oh it stopped flickering
when I go over there because the demon
scared me or whatever I'm like okay bro
it's a weird flex but okay so uh then
they said there were these like uh
window blinds in the kitchen and they
started kind of like swaying back and
forth even though there was no wind in
the house evidently
also um he said that there were again
wet Footprints Footprints or boot prints
kind of going through the living room
with no apparent cause there was that
also
and then Latoya started feeling kind of
weird
um said she felt like lightheaded had a
headache stuff like that and magino did
the whole like pushing the crucifix
under her forehead and stuff and then
she started like convulsing so you know
just acting like you're typical
possessed person
so Maginot Line had been there for four
hours
and basically he also came to the
conclusion he's like yeah you got like
[__] tons of demons in here also ghosts
because you can't just have demons you
have to have demons and ghosts like at
the same time he didn't really specify
what what was going on with the two of
them like are they fighting are they
like working together are they in tandem
what's we don't know but he just said
there's demons and there's ghosts in
here
so basically he did like a play he's
like look I don't have permission to do
like the full full-on
exorcism or nothing but he's like I can
do a blessing and in the meantime I
would suggest you get the [__] out
um you know just just for your own
safety so they didn't really have the
money to go anywhere so they ended up
just like and the kids have been taken
away at this point so it's just Latoya
and her mom
and so they
um go and like stay with a relative for
a little while so they didn't want to be
in the house anymore
now about a week after that they
actually did have to come back to the
house because uh DCS like the case
managers and the cops everything were
coming to again like assess the living
situation it was kind of the next step
in the process now so Rosa and Latoya
come back to the house but Latoya
refused to go into the house so Rosa had
to go in there and kind of like show him
around and tell them what was going on
and everything like that so again there
were like there were cops there and on
the document on the on the Zach
documentary which called demon house if
I didn't mention that
um they interviewed like some of the
cops that had been uh on a couple of
these uh you know excursions to go in
there and the one cop for sure I think
this is the one um
Charlie Austin I think was the one that
he talked to the most who was the
captain I'm pretty sure I can't like I
said they had a couple of different cops
on there and I can't remember like what
all their names were but he was um yeah
he was talking about like all kind of
creepy [__] that happened in the house
when they were there
so they um basically they're like okay
well they think that most of the
activity is coming from
the basement
now while the cops are there
um they're interviewing Rosa
and one of them has an audio recorder
because they're recording the interviews
right like a tape recorder
and the first thing that happened this
is very common in like Paranormal kind
of cases is that even though the dude
said that he had put new batteries in it
like just before he got there that when
he got in the house it seemed like the
battery like drained right away like the
little you know almost dead battery like
came on so it was that
and then while they were where's my yeah
I was gonna say yeah
you forget something
I'm like where's my liquids
but um so then like while he was taping
the interview like he didn't hear
anything at the time but like when they
played the interview back
evidently and they did actually play
this audio on the on Zach's documentary
was you know you can hear people talking
like uh you can hear Rosa talking and
some of the cops talking and stuff like
that and then there's a voice which kind
of sounds like it's saying hey like that
and they're saying that that wasn't
there nobody heard that like when so
it's like an EVP essentially was uh what
they heard so they did actually play
that audio it's kind of creepy but
there's a million different things it
could be you know what I'm saying
so um so yeah
also they took a bunch of pictures
while they were down in the basement
and one of the pictures and this wasn't
I think that um there's a misconception
that this was like an official police
photograph it was taken by a cop but it
wasn't like an official police
investigation but he just took it on his
iPhone or something you know what I mean
because he just out of curiosity so he
took a picture of like I think of like
the basement stairs because like if you
see because they on the documentary they
go inside the house you can see like
what it looks like so the basement it's
like it has a concrete floor but then
there's like these wooden stairs with
like these big gaps in between the steps
and then like underneath where the stick
where the steps are is like dirt it's
like a dirt Square for whatever reason
like they didn't put concrete over there
so evidently they took a picture
like of the steps or of something around
there and it had like this kind of cloud
of white Mist type situation going on
and if you looked at it real close
evidently I haven't seen the photo
although I think it was published in the
Indianapolis Star if I'm not mistaken
that you could kind of see a face and
then also there was like a greenish
Misty Cloud type situation too that kind
of looked like a woman's face or a
woman's body or something like that so
that supposedly came out in the picture
I haven't seen the picture personally
but I have seen I think one of the top
pictures that comes up in Google if you
Google this case is there's a picture of
the front of the house
and in the window it looks like a little
it doesn't actually look like a ghost it
kind of looks like a alien is what it
looks like but it's you know what I mean
it's just kind of like this white figure
type [__] like in the front window now
I'm pretty sure I'm 95 sure that they
found out later that that photo had been
like doctored obviously like somebody
just did it in Photoshop or with a with
an app on their phone or something so I
don't know about that but that's not the
same picture that they're talking about
evidently but so that is one that you'll
see if you do a search on it
so um so yeah
also the cop
uh Charles Austin that was the one that
was on the documentary right that he was
talking to all the time yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was him that's yeah I like the
captain and the cat the captain yeah he
seemed like a cool dude he's this big
old black dude he's got a good
personality
um
he's he saw something it scared him all
right yeah he seemed a little wigged out
yeah he was wigged out now some of the
stuff that some of the stuff
I think he jumped to certain conclusions
like he found some stuff underneath the
stairs yeah it was kind of odd
but it's mostly mostly odd and creepy
when you when you throw in the fact that
you think the place is haunted if you
didn't think the place was haunted lake
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a big deal
right like he's finding plates with the
candles in it and women's underwear
underwear and stuff like a like a Lee
press on nails yeah please press on now
that's just real common items if if you
didn't think the place was haunted you
wouldn't have thought anything about
that but he thought the place was
haunted so he read into that
yeah like somebody was doing some
rituals which is totally understandable
because when we were at Mammoth and it
[__] and it lowers this [__] place
when weird [__] was happening there
we would find objects and it would just
like what does this mean and then we'd
kind of like read into it a little too
much it was probably something just
random a random object would appear in a
place
the object didn't mean anything it was
just a random object you know
there wasn't a message I don't think in
a lot of the [__] that Poltergeist did
we just move a random object
and uh so that same guy that cop now see
this is where you're getting into a
little bit of a reach because I think
the implication that he was trying to
make was that whatever was in this house
had like followed him because he said
and I don't remember if they mentioned
this on the documentary or not but he
said that after he left the house
um he was driving home and the radio in
his police car like just went to static
for no reason and then when he was in
his own personal car later on that night
like apparently the um the the seat you
know like the automatic scene or
whatever started like going back and
forth on its own so he was having all
these mechanical uh malfunctions and I
guess he like attributed it to being in
the house like he had had some kind of
demonic [__] but like I said again
that's all a demon can do can like [__]
your radio up or like you know [__] with
your seat like in your car like Eh this
is bothering you is this bothering you
you know what I mean
it's like I don't know it just seems
like minor [__] and the thing about it
too like you said if you are seeing
everything in that framework yeah then
obviously every minor inconvenience that
happens to you after that you're gonna
attribute it to Demons exactly you know
so you gotta watch and I think that's a
lot of what happened with uh please with
police cabin
yeah
um he just started he got caught up in
it and read into into it too much and
we'll see how it happened to the other
um yeah to the other DCS lady too like
the second one like she kind of did the
same thing I think there was phenomenon
but I think they read into other things
you know yeah and and because like I
said to the phenomenon right it's like
oh you know oh my car broke down
I cut my finger while I was stopping
carrots I was walking I was walking and
I tripped and fell
and it went up in my booty
by accident so it was the ghost what
what happened everybody uh shampoo
bottle when I was in the shower I was
walking in the shower just walking in
the shower and it slipped in a shampoo
bottle went up my booty
and it is the ghost demons did it I'm
sure I'm sure that people in the
emergency room have heard that excuse we
see them this is why I come up with that
[__]
when I was at Fort Campbell on the 101st
they had the emergency evacuated dude
all right and [__] take him down to
[__] Fort Campbell Hospital oh I know
the story to take the [__] shampoo
bottle out of his booty yeah he said he
slipped and fell in the shower that's
what they all said
what was funny is that he was okay
what's funny is that
he was one of the few dudes in the
company that we knew was gay right yeah
we knew he was gay
no if it was back in the donuts don't
tell times you know what I mean [__]
didn't
we didn't give him a problem we you know
they were just they were just like one
of the one of the [__] crew but we we
were snickering though we were laughing
yeah it's like oh of course
that's right yeah you still fell yeah
okay well like I said I'm sure that I'm
sure we're not going to ask you any
questions don't tell us anything okay
I'm so like I said I'm sure like uh
emergency room uh staff have heard that
excuse me oh yeah because what are you
gonna say I mean you have like some
weird thing shoved up your ass he's got
to get it out somehow and then they're
gonna be like well how did this happen
you know yeah I mean I'm sure that like
but maybe some people have no shame
they're just like well obviously I stuck
it up in there yeah
duh what do you think I was gonna say
that I fell on it or something that's
lame no I stuck it up in there on
purpose and I was stuck in a slip
I heard a story once I don't remember
who I heard this from
but I heard a story one time and it's
like and I can't even remember what it
was but it was something that went up a
dude's butt and it was like something
weird it was it a lamp going I don't
remember what it was but it was
something and it went up to do or a
flashlight I don't know what it was but
um he said he didn't even say he slipped
and fell he said that he was painting
and he slipped and he fell off a ladder
yeah and then it went up his butt yeah
and I was like I find that yeah very
unlikely now I've told this story before
on the show
and and something went up a dude's butt
in the Army and everybody saw it and it
wasn't his fault
name was Sergeant Galarza he was real
popular oh this is [__] up this makes
me cringe every time I think about it
because you've told me this story yeah I
was sleeping
was sleeping in the company AO I was
being I was the CEOs uh it was the CEO's
[__] RTO at that time was I Was His
Radio operator I carry your [__] PRC
177 around or is it or which is the
[__] radio big heavy [__] radio
and I was just sleeping up the [__]
CP it was Command Post
and all of a sudden I woke up [__] we
were being attacked man was everybody
shooting at us with [__] blanket
blank ammunition this is that [__]
Fort Campbell CP got attacked we had
Humvees at the command post
and after the [__] little fire fight
we supposedly repelled him
there's a crowd of people at the front
of a [__] Humvee
and they're going to get the medicines
and they're just freaking the [__] out
and I walk up and Sergeant galar's just
standing in front of a [__] Humvee
going ah ah what's happening man what's
up and people are trying to help him I
couldn't understand what was going on
he had been impaled by a piece of
[__]
uh rebar
we had Humvees back in those days what
what the uh what the units would do take
a piece of rebar about three feet long
and [__] they would weld them to the
bumpers of a Humvee
and they would go up ins they would go
up off the end of the bumpers into the
driver's [__] View and they would put
like a little um
uh [__] tennis ball a little rubber
like tennis ball on either one of them
and that was to help him guide the
[__] vehicle into aircraft where they
could
real tight areas but mostly the loaded
inside of an aircraft
you know how much clearance you had
well he was standing on top of that
Humvee sleeping on top of the Humvees
what he was doing
and uh on its hood and when we got
attacked and he stood up started
shooting at the attackers and went to go
run off the edge and jump off the nose
of the Humvee
and his body weight [__] pushed the
ball down the river went up it went it
was about an inch over to his ass
and it went all the way up into his lung
and his feet were on the his feet was on
the ground and that piece of rebar was
going all the way up in his body and
he's everybody's grabbing ah he's
screaming they lifted him off of it well
yeah you got to leave him on there and
it was dark though I couldn't quite see
what was going on
and then a [__] Chopper came that's
awful they picked him up took him out I
can't imagine yeah yeah he came back a
couple weeks later to a standing ovation
we had the old company formation out
there and he's like he was all right
there took my virginity yeah yeah it was
[__] funny well I mean at least he
could laugh yeah yeah he's laughing he's
all right what they did what to him is
they [__] stuck a rod up in that hole
yeah with a [__] uh a swab on the end
and tried to clean it out right yeah and
then he just pulled it out and sewed him
up
because there's nothing you could do
well yeah he was fine totally recovered
that's crazy yeah Galarza Sergeant
garage I think he was from Salvador
originally he wasn't one of the contras
though God damn uh every time you tell
me yes like oh okay it just makes me
[__] cringe here this is the early to
mid 90s we had contrast one of my
[__] one of my squad leaders was from
the school of America's he was a contra
Rebel
he was [__] badass his wife had
tortured and [__] murdered like
several dozen people enemy sended eastas
I think and um
she was in a contra intelligence officer
and they got them out of that country
and they lived on they lived on in them
they absorbed them into the U.S army
that's how that was part of their deal
to give him safety they lived on
Military posts
his wife is badass but she was it was
funny at that time women couldn't serve
in combat units so
she was just a housewife living there at
[__] Fort Campbell but she was an
interrogator
yeah
bad ass [__]
Victor said a few months ago I had a
patient that had to have a glass Coke
bottle surgically removed from his
rectum he said he didn't know how it got
there
yeah yeah I don't know how I got there
man woke up does this
somebody must have broke into my house
and shoved a coke bottle up my ass while
I was here yeah there used to be a
[__] site back when the back when the
internet was Wild West it was called
Gore Gallery yeah I remember back in the
90s and they had all kinds of damn
X-rays of things that were up in
people's asses and you'd see those
x-rays you start laughing one of them
was a [__] toy double decker bus yeah
I told you my sister my sister used to
do um coding like billing coding for uh
for uh GI clinic yeah and she's like you
would be [__] horrified at all the
stuff all the [__] that goes around his
booties yeah she's like yeah and she's
like it's kind of hilarious like because
they got to build it you know like to
the insurance company yeah so she would
like tell me we gotta get back to this
one well yeah
I mean you know I I know how we should
do a whole show about like [__] that
people got stuck up their ass but you
know
it's the [__] stuck up their ass show
but yeah so uh so where was I okay
so like I said yeah so the cop
attributed like some car trouble that he
had later on that that evening to the
demon so like I said that's kind of like
a problem that we're gonna see
um with a lot of this case is that if
you already are primed to believe in
demons or like Supernatural or something
like that you're gonna kind of attribute
everything to that including
um stuff appearing in your ass and you
have no idea how it got there that's
what I mean I'm sure somebody has
probably come up with the excuses like
that that a demon did it or a ghost did
it so I mean that would be a good one at
least at least it's a little bit
creative
now so as DCs
are looking further into this case
they discover that before
um like I kind of feel like even before
the the claims of a haunting started
the kids had not been attending school
all that regularly
now the excuse that Latoya gave was
she's like well because of all this
demon possession nonsense that's been
going on
like the kids have either like the
demons either make them sick or keep
them awake all night so I usually like
keep them home but as far as I'm aware
allegedly
um I think that they had been missing
school off and on like even before like
the the claims of The Haunting starter I
could be wrong about that but I'm pretty
sure that I read that someplace
so at this point too like I said they
had some like a psychologist or
something like look into uh the kids
behaviors you know what I mean so
they're kind of like examining the kids
psychologically
one thing that the psychologist pointed
out was that the youngest boy the
seven-year-old
he noted that the psychologist noted
that the kid would only act possessed
um if you talked about demon possession
or if you
asked him questions that he didn't want
to answer
um they're like the rest of the time he
acted pretty much like a normal
seven-year-old but if you started
bringing up the haunting or if you
started like at like challenging him or
like asking him stuff that he didn't
want to give you the answer to then he
would start doing the growly voice and
the he would start like um doing that
so that seemed a little suspicious
um and one of the other doctors said
that uh it didn't really it's like the
kid didn't seem to have anything like
psychologically wrong with him
um but the psychologist did note that he
thought perhaps that the mom Latoya was
having quote unquote delusions that that
the kids were possessed and that the
kids were either
to please her or because they actually
believed it themselves because she
believed it were like trying to act in
accordance with her beliefs
yeah it could have been a Synergy yeah
maybe uh phenomena manifested itself the
mother believed that they were possessed
which helped ramp it up there wasn't
possession though that sounds like rspk
to me
that was the way it was with Janet from
the uh
from the Enfield Poltergeist case
it's a performance it doesn't mean it
isn't paranormal sometimes they can move
objects without touching them
and cause weird phenomena the only
phenomena I remember from this case
though is that he ran up a wall yeah
was there anything else that he had done
there were some claims of levitation but
that was prior to I'm not really sure
how many people witnessed that
everything else is just phantasmal
things right like I felt this I I think
this
um we found this
they didn't see anything move
not really
um yeah there was like footprints that
was kind of like there was more like
it's more like demonic kind of [__] like
oh there's a whale dripping from the
yeah that's a little bit of [__] like
that Poltergeist can do that though or
doors open and closing that kind of
stuff it's Poltergeist
oh Camp guy said they had that funny as
hell sketch on SNL called Appalachian
emergency room and Chris Parnell always
showed up with something stuck in his
butt
that's right you never know how things
can get up here
this is a strange world we live in
demons put it there you could just be
walking right
and you could you could just trip and
fall and when you wake up
something in your ass yeah it could be
amazing too you never know how did this
fire hydrant get my
somebody make a gif of that every time
I'm going how did this Firehouse
[Laughter]
I'm gonna make a gift yeah just you know
[__]
Zach knows all about it they didn't tell
us Zach
yeah and Camp guy said he always had a
crazy reason for it you see I get
because it happens yeah you never get it
it happens like you hold it no I mean
people do stick like all kind of wild
[__] up their butt and then like they
try to come up here yeah excuse yeah
rather than like just everybody knows
you're lying okay it always starts off
with I was walking yeah everybody knows
you're lying everybody knows that you
stuck that up your butt on purpose so
you might as well just admit it I was
walking
so they don't make a joke
just saying yeah just own up to it
everybody knows everybody knows how that
[__] got there
[Laughter]
it's a pro tip I know it's army man I
know I know it's embarrassing but you
know we've all done embarrassing things
little toy army men yeah
Hot Wheels cars
Mr Potato Head Mr Potato Head
with the eyes on and everything yeah
yeah
oh [__] yeah so
all right
so yeah so so like I said they've all
been evaluated and most of the
psychologists seem to believe that the
mom is you know her seeming to genuinely
believe
that the kids are possessed by demons is
making them act out like in order to
like I said to please her kind of or
because they believe the same thing that
she believes
that was what uh most of the psychology
most psychologists said
so
um so one of the cops Latoya and Rosa
the grandma and a couple other cops they
go to
um the house in May
and they and there's like there's a new
um DCS person because like Valerie
Washington the first one she was like
[__] that I'm not going back to that
house anymore because she was like
freaked out because she was there when
she saw the kid walk up the wall and she
was like yeah I don't want any part of
that
so they had to get a new person whose
name was Samantha illick so she was with
them at that point uh too
so they go around the house uh and they
had a canine with them as well
and apparently
um there was this weird this was another
thing that was kind of uh that happened
a lot in this case there was like this
weird oily liquid like kind of dripping
down the basement and they found it
later dripping down the window blinds
for some reason
um so well let me know it's um what's
that oily drippy stuff that's also
happened in the [__] entity case with
Taft was involved
all right we come out of walls yeah and
it's happened in other ones
I think Taft's case might be okay I
wasn't there
but was this being copy copied from
Taft's case because Taft shows up on
this [__] later on
well he didn't show up
um when it with the Ammons family yeah
he but he was on the Zack Biggins
documentary like so him and Zach like so
I think this was after the Ammons family
had left already and and after Zach
bought the house like I think he
contacted Barry Taff who like I said
Works a [__] Taff fan and red I
imagine and then well because he's a
kind of a well-known parapsychologist
right I mean like I said he's been on
some big cases so I think that that Zach
I can't remember like if he said he
contacted him about it or if Barry Taff
had already heard about the case and was
interested in it but they but he Barry
Taff is like in the documentary like
quite a lot and we'll get into that too
because I had actually forgotten about
that because it's been a few days since
I watched it but yeah so and that's
another thing too I think I think some
[__] that happened to Barry Taff after
this the whole thing with the house I
think he attributed it to like the
demons and [__] too even though it was
probably yeah so we'll kind of get into
that a little bit in a minute yeah when
I saw Taft in this I didn't realize how
little that [__] was
he's little you notice that not really
Taft got to be five [__] three yeah a
little bitty dude
murder Hornet said I heard a story that
a guy had constant diarrhea and he took
Caulking and squirted it up his ass to
try to plug it to try to plug it I guess
yeah it hardened and he had to go to the
ER after a few years
some idiot would do yeah it's like well
I don't need to ask I'm just gonna
[__] seal it up who needs an ass yeah
I don't need an ad yeah it's like that
maybe he had a hot date that night and
see maybe that's what it was he's got to
hold it in yeah and I can't I don't want
to [__] myself yeah I can't [__] myself
so I gotta I'ma [__] that [__] shot and
then I'll pop and [__] play but this
is the thing just get your butt plug
yeah why [__] it
yeah it's like they they do have butt
plugs you know they have all they have
all different kinds
all different kinds all different sizes
yeah
[Laughter]
jewelry on it
explain it to her that way booty jewelry
yeah yeah it's pretty to make the
sphincter look pretty right yeah they
even have it for cats yeah well you
don't stick it don't remove it yeah yeah
don't take that out don't take it out
you might regret it yeah
God we're so gross I think she's making
that up
you're making that up I don't know I can
see nobody's dead
oh that yeah oh I disagree I disagree
and she would back up
do you realize that
okay
South Park was correct somebody can
cough up a turd
we saw a [__] yeah it was called
Monsters Inside Me I still remember that
because I was horrified dude
accidentally he ate well yeah your
Elementary Canal it's all the way yeah
dude ate some uh food that he had
grilled and he didn't know it but the
grill had a damn metal bristle the meat
had a metal bristle from the grill
cleaning [__] brush and it got hung
up in his intestines and his food
started backing up he started vomiting
and started vomiting it out turds yeah
because nothing could come out the other
way right yeah because it like yeah
I never heard of such a thing man I
hadn't either and I was just like oh my
God
I mean but well once they mentioned I
was like oh yeah duh that makes total
sense because it's all one yeah you know
from your mouth to your ass yeah do not
you know for somebody who likes to cook
and I got a grill out there and griddles
and [__] do not have any kind of metal
scrub brush for a grill yeah no [__]
and after that I was just like oh my God
we're throwing them I don't even think
we have we didn't have one they're they
were all plastic but because the new
ones are all plastic but the old ones
were probably probably for that very
reason
[Laughter]
it's just a bristle [__] can break
loose and get it and he didn't even
notice he didn't notice it it swallowed
it
and uh [__] got hung up in his
intestines and [__] nothing could
pass through yeah caused a [__]
backup yeah so he started like vomiting
[__] which I was like
I can't imagine like much worse than
that to be honestly
yeah they did but it's like still it's
like I still would not want that to
happen doctors would know there's gonna
be an issue it took them forever to find
it though because it was so small yeah
they're like they knew they had to be
something in there but they couldn't
find obstruction yeah they couldn't find
it for a long time because it was so
tiny
but yeah so um yeah so they find this
weird liquid like in the basement
and then as I said they started digging
in the dirt like underneath this the
basement steps and they found a couple
things which like I said doesn't sound
it sounds a little bit weird but not
that weird but it only really sounds
weird like in the framework of oh my God
there's 200 demons in the house
so they found
women's underwear
they found a single like press-on nail
that I think was pink
and then they found like some toy like a
toy thing like a little red tin of some
kind [__] like that it just seemed like
just random [__] like it didn't seem
like super Sinister or anything like
that but they somehow were like ooh like
maybe somebody was buried or somebody
did a ritual down here and like summoned
all these demons or something like that
it seemed like they were trying to like
push it into that yeah right into it
they did yeah I kind of feel like a lot
of things that were were read into in
this case
so um so yeah so they get out the
Morton's uh the salt and they you know
kind of put it all in the hole and all
around the basement everything like that
because that solves demons also you just
go get some Mortons for a dollar and
that'll that'll fix you right up
so um basically then the other
caseworker Samantha illick
at this point she starts feeling really
weird and this I was like this is so
Random this is what she said and there
was a photograph of it on the onset the
Zach documentary and I really couldn't
see what the [__] she was talking about
but she says oh the right side of my
hand or like her Pinky and her ring
finger like on one hand it went all
white and numb like suddenly and there
was a picture of her hand which
presumably she took she's like look at
this you guys I'm like your hand just
looks like a hand it didn't look weird
or anything
um and she said she felt like it was
broken and she couldn't feel it and then
she started having like a panic attack
and like she couldn't breathe and she
had to run out the house
so
I don't know what that was all about but
I was like what what a weird thing to
say though it's like oh the demons are
[__] with two of my fingers and then
she and it just went white and it's like
but then she took a picture of it and
her hand just looked normal to me but
you know what I mean people were
attributing any little thing to these
[__] ghosts that's what I mean it's
like oh look I have like weird little
twinges of pain all the time I don't
like attribute it to Demons you're just
kind of like oh I wonder what that was
and then it just passes and you forget
about it oh [__] Jack in the Box gave me
some [__] up fries ghost did it
yes
that's what I mean it's like I can't
imagine being the kind of person that
would attribute just like stupid little
everyday annoyances well that everyone
has they were afraid I know but like a
mass panic
yeah it definitely does yeah like a
witch Panic yeah
so yeah so this is the second DCS lady
and you know because the first one she
was like [__] that I'm not going back to
that house and she wouldn't even come
back so they had to get a second one who
I think volunteered and like she came
there and she's like look my hands all
[__] up and I'm having a panic attack
I'm out I'm out of here so she runs
outside
and then Latoya who had actually come
into the house this time even though she
wouldn't before
she started feeling [__] up too like
she got a headache and she started
having all these like weird Phantom
pains and stuff and so she also had to
like run out to houses yeah and the cop
that we were talking about before the
captain that was interviewed on the um
on the documentary
um he's like he didn't like going in the
house either and he actually would not
go in there like after dark you know
what I mean he'd only go in there yeah
this actually all kind of checks out
with Poltergeist
um
if a poltergeist occurrence is happening
especially if it you're gonna have that
bad house feeling to it even if you
don't see any physical manifestations
and then you're gonna have a feeling
that some odd is happening there
and uh then your imagination will
[__] take over if you don't see it if
you don't see any actual phenomena you
might actually think you feel some [__]
and then you you're gonna or you might
see something's a little unusual and
you'll attribute that
to to the to to the [__] phenomena
that goes to the demon or whatever it is
you're calling it
so
I think they misidentified stuff but I
do think that they are that I think that
they're sensing that it's a bad house
although I will note uh and this is kind
of a spoiler alert that people who
because like I said they were renting
this house so they had a landlord so
landlord I don't remember how long he
had uh owned the house but it was quite
a while he was like an older man
and he had had tenants prior to this and
he had tenants after nobody else
reported any unusual activities just
those just that well if it's Poltergeist
it's not centered around the house it's
sitting around the kids but it didn't
follow them either did they follow the
kids no because they moved and nothing
else well sometimes the kids can move
and they think that they left the ghost
behind and yeah and they only lasts a
few weeks anyway of apologized yeah so I
might have just been that because I mean
they I think the the [__] went on for a
couple of years like before the couple
years I was it a couple years or maybe
it was a year or something like that but
yeah like eventually Janet's case out of
the infield Poltergeist
um case which is for me personally the
most credible case because it was
closest to mine and it was something
that my family actually saw
theirs was better I think Janet's lasted
about 18 months didn't it yeah it was a
year and a half about a year and a half
yeah yeah so which is unusual very
unusual usually it's only a few weeks
that's a noodle yeah
but yeah so um
so they're they're keep looking around
the house and like I said they found
this weird
oily substance I guess they meant there
was pictures of it it didn't look like
it just kind of looked like
olive oil or something like not even
like olive oil it just kind of looked
like [__] like a clear oil kind of so
they found this dripping down the window
blinds and they couldn't figure out what
it was or where it came from
so what they did was like they wiped it
all off the blinds and then they sealed
the room off
and then they went back in there like
half an hour later or whatever and they
said that the oil was all over the
blinds again so they couldn't figure out
where it was coming from like apparently
they tried to figure out what it was and
they couldn't figure it out
so magino the Reverend he says um you
know this is obviously demons because
you know how demons like to yeah put oil
on his on window blinds yeah so you know
what I mean that's it man everybody
knows that I've escaped the bowels of
hell so they can [__] slather some
[__] sit and go yeah slather some
[__] that's [__] up your blinds
yeah I'm putting some [__] yeah he's
some [__] canola oil yeah on your
window take that [__] yeah
extra virgin
yeah it's like that like I said it's
just all the Demonic [__] scenes just
seems a little lame that's all I'm
saying yeah so um so he's like okay well
this this oily thing this is obviously
you know we need to get get the big guns
for this so he actually writes to or he
contacts the bishop and asks for
permission to do an exorcism because
obviously you can't just do exorcism
willy-nilly like I said you have to get
permission to do that [__] now we talk
about the oil though yeah okay in the
Taft case there was oil
this is the entity case
and then they went and took they
collected some of that stuff and had it
analyzed and if memory serves
the results of the test came back as
being blood plasma
yeah didn't that sound about right to
you I think it was blood clots yeah that
was like on their kitchen cabinets
cabinets yeah that's right it's on the
little kitchen cabinets yeah I remember
the thing is is that
that's what they claim the results were
I didn't see the results they just said
that's what the results came back blood
plasma see you got to watch because a
lot of the Paranormal cases like
sometimes people just like say that and
then it just gets repeated right but you
didn't see the results they just said
that yeah like I didn't see the lab
result personally the lab results said
that it was blood plasma well where are
the results
you know which laboratory yeah I
remember seeing any of that I don't
think they posted any of that
so you can say anything yeah and back
then they couldn't really yeah and back
then it was harder to disprove you get
in check even though I think the entity
case was pretty compelling it had weird
there was weird things about it
but I don't know how much of it was true
really you never will know unless you
were there yeah
well that's kind of the thing it's just
the way it is it's just kind of
subjective though yeah me and Jen have
seen stuff together and
there'd be no way to document it or
prove it you just had to be there well
yeah and that's what I mean and it's
just kind of like and the thing about it
is like even if we had taken a picture
of it yeah or a video it would just be
it would just be the after effects and
the thing is we weren't I you know I
didn't even have my phone with me
because we weren't expecting anything to
happen we were just like I was just
sitting there like [__] watching a
movie like waiting like waiting for a
movie to start and it just happened we
were just surprised yeah remote flew off
TV flew off too so that's part of a
bunch of people yeah that's what I mean
so it's but no one was expecting that so
it's like no one was and you wouldn't
have been able to catch it anyway no too
fast it was well that's the way Mammoth
was but it was constant and there's
always where you weren't looking
yeah I don't think yeah I wasn't looking
at it yeah but it was in your field of
views but you weren't it wasn't yeah but
I wasn't [__] yeah it was like it was
about two or three feet like beneath
yeah eye line
but yeah so um so Maginot asks the
bishop Can we pretty please do an
exorcism Bishop says nah bro you can't
um he's like but you well you can do a
minor exorcism
can't do the big [__] which is like I
don't know why that's so funny to me
it's like they have like these different
stages of exercise like oh you can't do
the big one unless we say that you can
do it even though I'm sure it's like
it's not a big difference but whatever
he's like well you can do a minor extra
system just look that [__] up on the
internet
and like figure out how to do it
um so he does at the house he actually
does kind of what he called an intense
blessing
um and did a minor exorcism but he
didn't do it on the house he actually
did it on Latoya and she apparently kind
of had all kind of I think some of that
was recorded actually because there's
videos of it floating around out there
but she you know acted all possessy and
whatnot
so um
I think that the case manager Samantha
illick and a couple of the cops were at
the exorcism as well so this is like a
whole that's pretty weird having cops at
your exorcism but okay but like I said I
guess because DCS was involved and they
wanted to see what was going on with
this [__] before they'd let her have
the kids back is it time for commercials
yet
um yeah I guess so I mean I'm trying to
finish the case up but you know what I
mean no no have commercials and then
we'll take a break
I mean because it's quarter past nine
and I'm still trying to start commercial
every episode's gotta have some
commercials in it all right all right
all right we're gonna do some
commercials this is business man we'll
be back in a minute
foreign
[Music]
and
the death
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
so where were we
so intense blessing not and a minor
extras to the mom Latoya which like I
said she did a whole
possessed person kind of thing and like
cops were at the extras and everything
like that and see this is another thing
that I'm talking about okay so Samantha
ilik the other the the other DCS lady
she says that after
she attended this
blessing and exorcism thing
that she had all kind of things befall
her
uh she got really bad burns from a
motorcycle
she was in like a jet ski accident and
like broke some bones or something like
that so she was in like two or three
accidents like in the month I think
after the thing and she attributed all
of that to
demons basically like following her from
this thing
so
hmm
I mean I don't know like I said you
could just be unlucky I mean that it
happens sometimes it sucks but it
happens
I don't think every bad thing that
happens is demons no
but this is a mile poetry guy so like I
said it but see it does seem like even
though there's a lot of witnesses to
this case and I'm not trying to be mean
or anything like that but even though
there's it seems like there's a lot of
witnesses that saw this and the other
you have to think that a lot of these
Witnesses are really really quick to
attribute just regular random everyday
[__]
to Demons yeah like once they've been in
the house so they're already kind of
primed to believe in that kind of stuff
to start with so I don't know if they're
the most
credible or rational Witnesses that's
all I'm saying that's all I'm putting
out there you know yeah I don't blame
you right that's what that's how I I saw
it I think it may have been a real mild
Poltergeist case that caused a panic
I mean yeah if anything and like I don't
even know if I'm willing to go that far
but if if I was gonna go
in that direction that's probably what I
would say he's like yeah maybe they saw
a couple weird things and it was like
pretty weird but they flipped out about
it and then some things that weren't
probably weren't even related to that
they started like and then it just
snowballed I'm gonna say is my old
Poltergeist kid they said the kid ran up
the wall backwards I didn't see that
myself but there were several witnesses
that said that
you don't think that happened
um I'm not saying it didn't happen I'm
just saying that I don't know if it was
impressive as they made it sound made it
sound pretty [__] impressive
because I will note that
the kid was holding on to his grandma
the whole time
so it's he did have some leverage he did
have something to hang on to and like I
said it might not have been like as
spectacular as they made it sound
you know yeah
I'm just saying that's kind of what I
suspect okay but I'm you know what I
mean I'm I have to see it I'm really
skeptical yeah I didn't see it it
impressed him
I guess yeah I mean yeah maybe it was I
don't know like I said I wasn't there I
didn't see it yeah I'm just saying that
I don't think it would be impossible
for a kid who was hanging on to somebody
the whole time to do something like that
that maybe people be like holy [__] it's
a demon you know I don't know
uh Pammy says just found your channel
looking for the Magdalena Solis case oh
yeah we just did that not too long ago
yeah happy I'm catching alive that was
that thing that was that crazy Mexican
woman oh her yeah yeah yeah that's a
good case yeah that was a good yeah I
think somebody recommended that a long
time ago I'm glad they did because I had
actually never heard of her but whoo
that was uh that was something
uh Sebastian said is the Pro game on a
board or computer game looks fantastic
thank you uh it's a board game actually
I designed it a couple years back I like
to design board games I don't have as
much time to do it anymore but I have
done some I have some actually I might
have a Poe game back there someplace I
don't know I don't know where it's at
it's probably like wait this is a good
example oh well that's this is another
one I did this is a
yeah that's like absent that's based on
like absent stuff they're very good
quality games and this one is like an
Egyptian like tomb one
yeah
oh yeah that's the Mary Shelley one yeah
and then that one there's yeah you saw a
commercial for that one that's all about
um Mary Shelley and Chelsea show on the
back and Lord Byron and all that yeah
they're beautiful in there
yeah Jenny makes all those yeah I do
that for fun yeah and this one I don't
think he was out of commercials this is
a Halloween one
I did that one last year or the year
before show them the back but it's like
a Halloween game yeah it's a big board
it's a big board game I have the Red
Death one here somewhere but I don't
know where yeah where is that it's
probably like it's probably underneath
all the [__] over there
gorgon's Lair oh yeah that's the Medusa
one and then you got a shiny game that's
well I didn't design that when you
bought me that one okay yeah here it is
it's underneath
oh okay so it's underneath all this
stuff yeah don't don't can't get it yeah
yeah don't [__] with it don't [__] it
but uh but yeah it's similar it's all
the same quality yeah I use um the game
Crafter
you can like upload all your stuff and
they will print the games for you though
it's really it's good and then you get
like you know they get a huge percentage
and you get a small percentage Yeah well
you can take all your [__] well no I
mean you can price it everywhere you
want to price they they gave you a they
give you a base price it's like this is
how much all your components cost and
then you add however much you want to
add on to it so you get enough
commission right right yeah for each one
that you sell but they only print them
when you sell one yeah I'm working on
one now like just off and on like
whenever I have time which I hardly ever
do but um I'm doing one now that's like
based on like Victorian spiritualist
seances
you know what I mean so that's just
gonna be a card game I'm trying to make
it like really cheap girl is
multi-talented
mixed games that's my favorite shows
honest looks makes porn
it's true I'm a Renaissance woman yeah
honestly I and I think I've said this
before but if I had my druthers I could
just
probably designing games is my favorite
thing to do because it incorporates
everything that I like because you kind
of have to write a story too so that it
incorporates like the writing aspect and
it also incorporates like a design
aspect like an art aspect and I just
really and I've I find it really
satisfying like putting all those things
together
so if I only could do one thing like
that I could make money I would probably
just do that like I would design
board games by the way I know but it's
expensive to um I I looked into it they
want money well yeah yeah I mean you
know how much do they want to play the
game
um if you sponsor yeah half of a show
yeah I think it's six hundred dollars
okay all right I think it's 900 to
sponsor one whole one right you probably
wouldn't get the sales
that's what I mean I'm not really sure
if I would I mean they're a hugely
popular show and like if they like your
game then people would probably buy it
but I don't know if I can justify that
much Expendable even if I had the money
which I don't but yeah at that at that
commission rate though you have to sell
a [__] ton yeah I would have to sell
them to recoup because I don't I mean
some of those games I don't make that
much money off of them because all the
components are expensive because I
wanted them to look nice you know yeah
and you know the components are not
cheap
so I didn't want to cheap out on the
[__] but like I said the one I'm working
on now just like I've been working on it
for like
a year because it's just like I never
have time to work on it but I'm trying
to make it like under 25 like but it's
just gonna be like a card game it's not
gonna have board or anything anything
like that so um so yeah so we're almost
through this yeah so so Samantha like
had all of these
misfortunes before she was like in in
some accidents and broke her ankle and
like she slipped on the ice or some [__]
like that so she kind of attributed all
that to Demons she was like oh my God
like the demons are [__] with me or
whatever
now also and I think here's the thing
imagine oh he believes in demons too
obviously that's kind of his whole bread
and butter
but he also kind of it was maybe
allegedly encouraging Latoya like maybe
in her delusions if that's what they are
um saying is like oh you should look on
the internet it's like and see if you
can figure out which demons are in your
house that are like playing you because
they're all different you know and so
she's like apparently she's like looking
up on the internet going oh yeah that
sounds like some like the D like one of
the Demons that's [__] with us and
stuff like that and listen like please
don't encourage that kind of stuff but
yeah so that's what they're doing
so after they did the minor exorcism
then I guess the bishop was like okay
you can do the big deal exorcism now you
big baby like okay finally you can do it
so they do the major exorcism the real
exorcism I guess but you know it's
official so I guess it's like more
it works better I don't know it's more
demon repelling I suppose
now so they actually ended up magino
actually ended up I think they did three
exorcisms they they did two in English
and one in Latin so that's when you know
it's serious when they're doing like the
[__] Latin exorcisms because demons
[__] hate that they [__] hate it
they come at them with Latin it's
[__] over man they go we gotta get
the [__] out of it we're going all right
which is too goddamn old God damn it
it's too old it's too efficient we gotta
get the [__] out of here
laughs
imagine it Max von seidelity
maximum side out he can exercise some
demons that's for sure
but yeah so uh so yeah so they did three
exorcisms on the [__]
so
um basically
so a year later so I guess this all did
happen over the course of a year because
it was November 2012 and I think they
first started reporting stuff in
November of 2011 so this is over a year
that this happens
so the kids
um finally get returned to Latoya
because I guess they've
figured out
they do all these exorcisms they're like
oh well I guess it's okay now like it's
okay for the kids to go back I guess
that they had been taken away like six
months before so they were in like State
custody for quite a while
so she gets the kids back in uh November
of 2012.
and they
moved
um they did actually I don't know where
they got the money from but they did
actually save up enough money and they
moved to Indianapolis
and reportedly
um they didn't have any more Paranormal
Activity
after they moved
now I will note a few things a couple of
these things I've sort of alluded to
earlier in regards to
um perhaps um considering this case was
a little bit of skepticism
uh as I said several doctors and
psychologists that looked into the case
because like I said there were a lot DCS
was involved there were cops involved
everything like that a lot of the
doctors seem to think that Latoya not
she didn't necessarily um display any
signs of mental illness but she might
have had some kind of um
she was very very religious and that she
might have had some kind of like
religious delusions she did seem to
genuinely believe that the children were
possessed and so they speculated that
her belief in this regard might have
made them
act in that manner because they thought
it was what was expected of them
um and a couple of the psychologists did
say that they thought that the kids were
doing that to please their mother
basically because that they thought that
that's what she wanted
um so there was that
also as I mentioned
um they had very very irregular School
attendance uh Latoya was saying that it
was because the demons were making them
sick or keeping them awake and so she
had to keep them home all the time
however I believe that reports of their
uh truancy I guess if you want to put it
that way
um came from before the reports of The
Haunting started so this had been going
on before that
so there's that as well uh you know I
think there were some complaints as far
back as like two years before the
haunting [__] started like in 2009 like
that the kids weren't going to school
and
and uh you know and there were other
things going on like that so there had
been complaints filed against her a
couple of years prior to the haunting
Shenanigans beginning
so there was that
um also the landlord whose name was
um Charles Reed I think was the guy's
name
he said that um none of his other other
tenants uh had ever uh complained to him
of any Paranormal Activity uh either
before or after she had lived there he
also noted that the alleged Paranormal
Activity began when Latoya got behind on
her rent and uh she subsequently did not
pay it so that was that going on too and
he thought that she had just started the
story so she wouldn't have to pay for
anything
um and as I mentioned previously a lot
of the psychologists that uh interviewed
the children when their mother was not
present would act completely normally uh
for their age group or whatever unless
uh the psychologist brought up the
haunting or brought up demons in any
form then they would start acting like
kind of crazy or if they asked them
questions that they didn't want to
answer like uncomfortable questions then
they would start like acting all like
wrong you know what I mean they would
start doing that kind of [__] and they
thought that was very suspicious
so as I mentioned earlier so the so the
family got out they lived there for
about a year and then they [__] off
they went to Indianapolis and reportedly
did not uh you know didn't have any more
paranormal activity after that at least
as far as they said
so Zach Bagans
as uh you know from Ghost Adventures
obviously
he got interested in this case and he
bought the house in 2014 for 35 000.
and he's gonna make a documentary in it
now me and Tom watch this documentary a
couple nights ago I encourage you to
watch it it's good it's it's actually
pretty entertaining it's funny yeah I
didn't think it would be I thought it'd
be boring as [__] yeah but it was
actually pretty entertaining I thought I
don't I didn't believe much of it no I
don't believe any of it either but it
was still like pretty entertaining
episode well like I said because good I
I was skeptical because
um I don't like Ghost Adventures I think
it's boring as [__]
um because nothing happens and it's like
you know and it's very clear that
they're trying to make the show
interesting by pretending that shit's
happening but nothing's really happening
but this was actually interesting and it
wasn't interesting because they were
pretending [__] was happening it was
interesting because of like the
interviews with the people who were
involved and he actually did like to his
credit he did actually get interviews
with a lot of the principals involved
like some of the cops and um he
interviewed the uh Valerie Washington
the original DCS lady and various other
people and a couple of the relatives of
like um of Latoya Ammons like I think it
was her brother or her brother-in-law or
something like that so he had like
interviews with that and he did actually
get hold of
um the the police footage like when they
went like when them and the cops in the
DCS like went through the house and like
filmed it and filmed the interviews he
did actually have a lot of that in the
documentary the weird audio [__] you
know with the ghost saying Hey or
whatever he had that so it's like he did
like make an effort it's not like a slap
Dash Affair it's like a well put
together documentary and he did actually
like have a lot of substantive
information in it which I thought was
good
um do I think it's all [__] yeah but
the thing about it is that so he buys
the house
and he okay I will say he tried to
interview
Latoya and Rosa like he found out where
she lived
in in Indianapolis and because he had
seen her on the news or something like
that like about some other unrelated
thing
so he found out where she lived and went
there
and it turns out
and I actually uh confirmed this a
little bit later on
they wouldn't talk to him
because I think they wanted it to seem
like oh it's we we don't want to talk to
Zach because it's like you know it's the
whole thing's behind us and it was like
too scary and we don't want to like get
demons possessing us again or anything
like that but and I again I will give
him credit he did seem to imply that
they didn't want to talk to him because
they had already made a deal
to sell their story to someone else and
they didn't want to [__] that up
and when I was looking online I did find
out I found an article from June I
believe of 2022.
that there is I don't know if it's ever
going to come out but as of June 2022
there was a movie coming out about this
called the Deliverance uh it had
apparently been cast
um I don't know if they started shooting
it yet or what the deal is with it but
there was an article about it that said
that you know so
so I don't know so I I think that kind
of like I said that doesn't necessarily
mean the shit's not true but
there does seem to be like a little bit
of a financial sounds like they're
trying to make another [__] mode
right because they didn't want because
wasn't there a thing because there's a
scene in the documentary where Zach is
talking to
I'm assuming he's talking to like a
producer or somebody like that that was
trying to purchase the story
and they were trying they were
threatening to sue him because he was
making a documentary about it and
they're like no we we purchased the
rights to that story like to make a
movie about it I thought that's what
that whole exchange is about it's odd
that he bought the house and then tore
it down okay now there's a way no way to
confirm the claims yeah well that's one
thing yeah and okay so here's the thing
like in the documentary so like I said
they mostly you know he talks about
buying the house but then he kind of
goes back and talks about the case he
interviews some of the people like I
said the police captain that was there
like he's interviewed at quite at length
um you know the DCS lady Valerie
Washington like some of the people like
that um and they have you know police
footage of Rosa and all this other stuff
and then they have like some
reenactments of like the kids doing
demonic [__] and everything like that
which are actually pretty good it's like
it's pretty well staged
but then um he goes into like probably
the second half of the documentary he
goes into the thing where it's like
we're gonna see if there's really
something in this house and toward the
end he does kind of like a stunt thing
where he's like I'm gonna seal myself
into this house
like overnight like to see what happens
so it's like and like I said it seemed a
little like a like a stunt you know what
I mean he's like I'm gonna put plywood
over all the windows so I can't get out
like plywood over all the windows and
doors he's locking himself in there so
he can't get out
overnight like to see if anything
happens and so then you know he's like
yeah they make it seem like pretty
creepy and scary like he saw something
or heard something or anything and prior
to that they also try to imply too
because remember there were the scenes
where Zach and his crew were in the
house and then remember like Zach and
that other dude like the camera guy or
whoever the [__] it was and then they
started like arguing or fighting and
then Zach is like pushing the dude
against the wall and he's like all like
people [__] one he's like
fighting with him and stuff and then
like he comes out after he's like I
don't know what happened so he's like
trying to imply that like whatever's in
the house is like possessed him or
something without coming out and saying
it and then there's like this whole
thing where this other dude that's on
the crew like just loses his [__] he's
kind of like because remember they
they're in the house and he starts
acting the other dude like starts acting
really weird and he's like wandering
around like going down in the basement
and he's just like like he's acting real
weird and then they go back to the Hotel
later on and the dude is just like
screaming like at some at nothing like
in the elevator and he's just like
acting all crazy and like threatening to
kill people and [__] like that and I'm
just kind of like it seemed a little
over the top I'm just gonna say but I'm
just saying they didn't come out and say
that they thought like demons were
possessing them but that was clearly
what they were trying they wanted you to
come to that conclusion that like the
demons were affecting their behavior now
even though he didn't come out and say
this outright either
I feel like Zach would say that his
explanation for having the house
demolished which he did in 2016 which is
why it's not there anymore
was well I don't want anyone else to
live in this house and get possessed by
demons or whatever because apparently
him locking himself in there over the
night like with all the plywood and
everything like on the windows and doors
that was like the last straw and he was
like it was so terrifying that he's like
no one should have to
uh experience this so it's like I'm just
gonna tear this down and be done with it
my theory though is that one yeah like
now nobody can go in there and like
check and be like hey nothing just prove
it nothing's going on in here it's just
a regular ass house but two I think he
just needed like a real dramatic ending
for the documentary yeah and you're also
locking down the story
now it's over it's over and nobody else
can can add to it or right or debunk it
yeah you're just saying you're
definitively like ending it right which
is when you look at a more I would say
more uh
believable investigator it's like Steve
like Steve Mara Dave he would go no
we're going to keep the house here let's
keep studying it that's you know like I
mean that's what a scientist yeah and
you guys we gotta figure this out right
yeah you guys go in there and see if you
guys get possessed you know just
go on see if you get
if you tear it down that means you're
protecting your version of the story
yeah like you said he's locked it down
and and like I said I think he also
wanted it to be like a dramatic and
because he's like oh man I stayed
looking at this house yeah I stayed
overnight this house and it was
horrifying I didn't want to talk about
it
um you know I'm getting rid of I don't
want anybody else to have to go through
what I went through I think where did
you move though it was like a really
really true because now all the Rubes
but it's all PR yeah it's all PR and now
Rubes to go well they tore it down
because it was evil like a man shouldn't
do and that yeah and that's exactly
that's exactly what he wanted to portray
yeah right like I you know I'm being
magnanimous I don't want anyone else to
go through what I went through when I
was in this house overnight so I'm
getting rid of it you're welcome that's
kind of yeah but like I said it was
certainly a dramatic ending for the
documentary like you know having the
[__] bulldozers come in there and
like tear it down and everything
this is the best haunted house in the
world let's destroy it
yeah which and to me okay and here's
another thing
um I have so many questions so
so let's Okay so theoretically let's say
that this house really did have 200
demons in it which I don't believe but
I'm just saying theoretically just for
argument's sake
um so you tear down the house or the
demons will where do they go they're
just like oh [__] the house is gone now
we have to like dissipate you gotta go
back to hell
well they were saying it was important
can't they just hang out I think even
the cops said that you know the police
chief the police captain said it was
what difference portal portal what
difference does it make to a demon
whether the whether the house is there
or whether it's just the land yeah I
mean you'd think that demons wouldn't
give a [__] one way or the other yeah
they're demons these are stories that
are kind of kind of told by people that
don't understand quantum physics who've
never had who've never had any kind of
out of body or near-death experiences
from my point from from from my point of
view haven't seen that kind of stuff
if there were things like demons
they'd be able to come in and out of
this Dimension it will they would that's
what I'm saying
no
so it's just every single story that I
ever hear about like oh this house and
like I said we watch a haunting a lot
and all that other kind of stuff so it's
like every single thing it's like oh
it's a demonic entity it's like they
just seem really lame it's like it just
seems like they could do if they were
actually demons they could do a lot
worse [__] than the stuff you see them
doing and they wouldn't be hemmed in by
these false limitations that we are
imposing on them right that's why I
don't think they exist I think that's so
like I said so Zach tears the house down
and I'm just kind of like if they were
really like [__] demons then they
would just hang out and be like bro we
don't need the house
we'll just [__] you up from here we
could [__] you up from anywhere we're
demons when I was happy when I had that
Obe
had an out-of-body experience I came
aware that there were bad things
in what you would call the spirit world
but they were mostly weak
yeah I mean they really couldn't do
anything to you
so the idea that they could come to this
Dimension and
do something bad nah
not really I don't think so
yeah I'm just I don't buy it I just
don't buy it all the good [__] was in
the pleroma
and if you went in there there was no
way no way you were going to come back
out
you'd be recycled
because that we did a whole video on
that Jenny knows what I'm talking about
yeah yeah Deontay Barlow says is demon
scary well what demons in general or
demon house this documentary I did not
find it scary no but I mean your mileage
may vary
incurable Skeptics yeah I mean you know
I just there's just a lot of stuff we're
not as good as we've seen well yeah but
I'm skeptical of most things just
because there's too many let's make this
up there's just too many questions that
it raises and it's like I don't really
okay best at best this was a minor
Poltergeist case that caused a panic and
then other guys jumped in to try to make
something out of it and then they fanned
the flames
at best
might have just been a paddock yeah can
we talk to and like I said you have to
think that most of the people most of
the principles involved in this case
from the beginning even the cops even
the nurses even the DCS people
were already believed in demons yeah and
I mean this is a very religious yeah and
they already thought the place was
haunted right so so you're if you're
already primed to believe that kind of
stuff then like even like real innocuous
[__] could happen and you could like be
like oh [__] demons you know what I'm
saying you know you can go to the just
the the police captain he's a nice guy
and I think he's actually got some
street cred to him
but like you said he had a religious
background he believed the place was
haunted and any little thing in there
spooked him
maybe it did have a [__] weird Aura
to the place
maybe there was something Poltergeist
going on there
which added to added to the [__]
feelings
but he never really claimed to see
anything impressive not really it just I
mean he was weirded out by the photo
that he took like on his iPhone which
but that was just like a Mist type thing
which could have been a lot of things it
could have been his [__] finger for
all yeah the place weirded him out
can we talk about speaking of that can
we talk about just for a second on the
on the Demon House documentary there was
a and they made much of this they kept
showing this clip like over and over
again and this was when someone on
Zach's crew they were filming around in
the house and apparently they weren't
filming anything in particular they were
just kind of doing a run-through of the
house and there's a thing where they
walked by the cameraman walks by the
bathroom like the bathroom's over here
on the side and they're walking toward a
bedroom or whatever it is
and there's like a um like a black
shadow that kind of goes shoot like that
like in the bathroom right
oh yeah I remember that right so they
made a big deal out of it but they're
like we didn't see this when we were
going through the house and it's like we
just saw it we were like looking at the
footage afterward and I'm looking at it
and I'm like that's a finger that is
bro's finger yeah I mean I'm pretty sure
and then it it was and it happened on at
least two occasions
and they had the audacity to come out
and says by the way this is not a finger
doing this
because they knew it was a finger well
see that's what I mean because they knew
that everybody would like us would be
like that's that dude's fingers finger
from the line so he yeah this so the
dude very specifically like the the
photo it wasn't even Zach it was like
the photo yeah the analyzer guy was like
it's not a finger and I was like no I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure it's a
finger because it's blurry and it's just
kind of a shadow yeah it kind of looked
like if yeah if you were like with a kid
and you kind of went like that yeah
because it kind of went when you had
your finger and you had your finger out
like that that's what it kind of that's
what it looked like to me I don't know
it didn't look like uh
like I said if you're gonna say that
that's a [__] demon it better look
like a [__] demon and not like a
shadow of your [__] finger and that's
all I'm saying because that's what it
looked like to me yeah but then like I
said I thought it was very instructive
and so did you because you laughed when
the dude said it yeah that it's like
that he specifically came out and said
it's not a finger yeah I laughed
immediately because that's that's the
first thing we said I'm like that's it
it's figure you're just going like that
the gaslighting well that well yeah and
yes well that's a good
um and I don't know if they're doing it
on purpose but that's like a good
psychological trick to use if they know
that Skeptics are going to come out and
say hey that's someone's finger or
that's a bug or like if it's an orb or
something then they'll be like that it's
not that we checked you know what I mean
like we thought of that too but that's
not what it is like they're trying to
make you feel better but I'm like nah
I'm pretty sure that's still a finger I
mean that's what it looked like to me
it didn't like I said if you're gonna
film some [__] and there and you're
trying to convince me there's a demon is
that better [__] look like a
demon like definitively like a demon
don't show me some Demon that just looks
like your goddamn finger yeah or like a
hair or a [__]
mosquito flying in front of the lens
real close or something like that like
show me some [__] that's like well
although if they did show I mean to be
fair if they did show me something
definitive I'd be like yeah you made
that [__] After Effects so I don't
know
so I think our uh our verdict is is that
it was a hoax based upon a panic
probably
yeah I'm not saying that nothing weird
happened in that house maybe something
did I don't know I wasn't there but then
they jump on it and they try to monetize
this [__] and [__] turn it into
something that it wasn't and they're
real they make a panic based upon that
because if you have Outsiders coming in
spending money on it
and giving it more attention then the
locals all of a sudden go yeah there is
something wrong with that place
and then they get even more panicky
yeah any little thing that happens to go
it's the ghost I mean because it's very
human for people to want to believe in
creepy mystery stuff yeah you know not
not everybody's an [__] like me that
wants to debunk everything
most people aren't
so it's I've seen some creepy [__] you
can't deny it when it's really creepy no
I know I'm just saying and I'm not
saying this [__] doesn't exist yeah I'm
just saying that 99 times out of 100
yeah there is a completely normal act
the rational explanation creepy [__]
tends to be very rare and very Elusive
and doesn't last long
um if you run into it you know what it
is when you see it there's nobody you're
gonna call
and it's not going to last very long and
nobody will believe you so you're just
gonna let it ride yeah I think that [__]
moved or I felt like something was
watching me
but it's gone now you know what I mean
[__] what am I gonna do I'm just
gonna let it go it's gonna be [__] like
that
and there's there is something to it
I've been there
but
a little phenomenal like that that I
think is real
that I think means something it's hard
to monetize that you can't make a movie
out of that
I was right under staircase I swear to
God somebody's watching me
swear to God every time I go over there
somebody's watching me you can't make a
movie on that yeah it'd be really boring
really that's boring so it's got to be
more than that yeah I mean if you're
gonna go the full Amityville route I
mean you better have bleeding walls and
[__] demons in the basement and [__]
like you I mean make it sexy you need to
like you need some over-the-top [__] to
happen
which makes it less believable obviously
but it's like it's gonna be more likely
because you know reports of oh I felt
creepy in this or I thought I saw a
shadow I mean that's a dime a dozen yeah
if you're gonna get Hollywood to come
calling if you're gonna get a book deal
you gotta have something
sexy you gotta have something that's
like original a little bit like a little
bit of different take on it you gotta
have like some crazy [__] happening yeah
nobody's gonna just watch a movie about
somebody having feelings about you yeah
that you're in a place and you feel like
you're being watched constantly right
and it's a heavy oppressive feeling
that's not I mean it's not exciting for
other people to watch that's all I'm
saying right and in my experience that
kind of [__] exists it's not this now
the Poltergeist experience which happens
some of the things did move and
everybody saw it
but it wasn't quite what they're
describing here and it's not a quite
what an Amityville Horror not quite what
you saw in Exorcist that's
in some ways cooler but another way is
[__] not quite as impressive
see like I said I'm kind of one of those
weirdos that I mean when when they make
horror movies not based on true stories
or anything like that but um
when I watch horror movies or read about
a supposedly true case whether I believe
it or not
it subtler [__] is creepier to me but I
know that I'm in the minority on that
yeah to me like if [__] is
um more subtle but also without context
to me that's a lot creepier than just
like oh I saw a demon walking through
the house I'm like that's not scary to
me I mean yeah it'd probably be scary if
it happened to me in real life I'm not
saying that but I'm just saying that
like reading about it or watching in a
movie that's not scary like I don't and
I don't know why that is I feel like
subtler [__] is scarier to me just
because there's no explanation for it or
there's no reason for it there's no
context behind it and to me that's like
scarier that was like that house me and
Eric moved into Boston after we got out
of the army
everybody that went in there all our
girlfriends that would come hang out
with us it was just a bad place it just
felt like you were being watched
constantly just this oppressive
Darkness
just it was just a bad place
you'd have bad dreams there
but nothing ever moved you can could and
I couldn't prove it
I felt like I got attacked that's what I
mean everything was internal yeah it's
all I didn't see anything
you know I felt like eyes were spinning
around me watching me bearing down on me
one time and like it was trying to
push me down into the ground what it
felt like but I couldn't see anything
and uh
I just threatened it said I'm gonna burn
your [__] house down
then it went away
he's like okay this is your house I know
this is your house and I'm gonna burn
your [__] house down you know what I
mean I [__] I said I'm gonna go get
some gasoline out of the [__] car I'm
gonna burn this house down and it went
away
see the only time in my whole life that
I've ever had that sensation yeah where
I was in a place and I'm like I don't
like it in here and I get it the [__]
out yeah I was in a [__] Big Lots
yeah you told me about that yeah
I have never had that happen and I don't
and I still can't explain it I don't
even remember what I went in there to
buy some Tupperware that's what I wanted
to buy what are they where did I buy
Tupperware in a Big Lots in Daytona
Beach yeah and I went in there and I was
in there I made my way over to the aisle
where the [__] was and I started feeling
like I need to get the [__] out of here
like this is something really bad it's
gonna happen yeah and I had never felt
like that ever well that's what that
house was like right that's what I mean
that's the only time I've ever felt and
it would it would subside sometimes but
it would never totally and then
sometimes it would ramp up
and Eric could feel it too
and it was but nothing ever happened
like nothing ever moved
we had to walk our girlfriends to the
bathroom and then we had to wait outside
the bathroom door we were pissing
because they didn't want to walk down
the hallways by themselves and it was it
was a creepy kind of looking house it
was just a little Victorian house
but the Boston is filled with those yeah
it's just that particular one was a bad
place
um
for you Star Wars fans man the only
thing I could describe it is it was a
place that was strong with the dark side
of the force
kind of like where Yoda was hiding not
on Dagobah we're [__] Luke saw The
Apparition of [__] Invader and [__]
it was it was a place like that
something bad had happened there
some kind of residue was like and the
house was about 125 130 years old it was
old
it's weird because I spent a lot of time
in my grandfather's house when I was
growing up and my mom and all her sister
and all her uh siblings rather she had
seven siblings and they all grew up in
that house and they all reported
um haunting [__] like they'd had
blankets pulled off them like they heard
footsteps on the roof all the time [__]
like that and I was in there all and I
was always kind of because I loved that
house I thought it was it's been torn
down now
but um I love that house but I never and
I always wished that I experienced
something there but I never did it was
creepy but in a cool way like I never
felt creeped out in there ever like I
just I thought it was just a cool
[__] house I never got scared in
there yeah but they did apparently but I
never felt anything in there which I
always thought was really weird right so
I don't know if it was just
because I was I was always like really
excited I'm like man I wish I could like
see some [__] ghosts or something
like that but I never fashion ass but
about a math Mountain uh [__] recap
recap yeah we might be able to do
something like that yeah we did a we did
a recap where I think we updated
because I think we had pictures of the
place from that was like a few years
back we did that knew her pictures where
we had newer pictures of it where you
were like talking about it but I think
that might have been
now that I'm thinking about it that
might have been even before we had a
video component no because I think we
have a slideshow that's right I think it
was a slideshow because we found like
new photos yeah of the same place
because you were talking about how much
had changed and how much I had little I
might even be able to give the address
away because nobody owns the place
yeah nobody owns that now oh that's
right yeah it was on Zillow for sale
yeah we saw like that particular condo
yeah the condo usually changes hands
through companies that use it as like a
vacation house yeah that's what it was
when you were yeah nobody lives there
yeah it's like an it's like an executive
perk yeah
um it's owned by well back when you
stayed there it was owned by an oil
and they would like let the executives
like vacation there like yeah
or whatever but it was empty when no one
was staying in it yeah it's like a you
know you can go skiing it was like a ski
resort type thing but I I can give away
what it is because you see that that
phenomena was not location based because
we left there and it followed it yeah so
you could go go to that place and it
would be safe nothing would happen there
it was emanating
from me and my uncle my aunt my cousin
that's the Synergy that was happening
and mostly me and I think that I mean
that has kind of been proven
definitively because
we we still have [__] happen we haven't
had a [__] happen for a while yeah but
at the old house a couple years back we
had a
couple months where some [__] was
happening you've had some [__] happen
here but just real minor and the reason
for all that [__] you see why'd that
happen it's psychological at that time I
didn't like my family I wanted to join
that family I wanted to live with my
aunt my uncle I didn't want to live with
my parents
so that part of it
so you were kind of like I created that
thing to get us to bond together I guess
a common foe that's the [__] yeah
subconscious reason
uh but
Red's dead now he remembered more of it
than even me or my aunt he he brought up
all kinds of phenomena that ended up in
the book though
well yeah because I I mean before I
interviewed him and Lois extensively
yeah before he died and also your cousin
Wesley yeah um actually I couldn't
interview him but he sent me a letter
yeah he's deaf and autistic so a lot of
stuff that he says does didn't quite
make sense he sent me a letter though
where he talked about like differences
yeah
is some of what he said is in the book
but he changed his story a lot because
sometimes he would say no that didn't
happen it didn't you know like red made
that up and I was like no no that did
happen
and then he'd get scared he didn't want
to talk about it so he did see stuff he
was in denial about it
yeah he didn't really it was kind of
weird like how he experienced the whole
right
the whole thing he was deaf and autistic
and
he was young we were both real young at
the time 13 Maybe
it's a real interesting story and like I
said I was scared though yeah yeah
Sebastian said I'll order the book it
sounds very good oh you'll like it I
mean yeah true it's um
well it in case you didn't know like I
you know I'm real skeptical about
paranormal kind of stuff and I think
that Tom yeah
did not want to tell me about this for
like a really long time
but he did finally tell me about it and
at first I did I don't want to say like
I didn't believe it
because clearly he believed it
and I was just kind of like that sounds
pretty
um that sounds pretty out there and he's
like he's like here's what I want you to
do he's like I want you to call my aunt
and uncle in California because they
still live in California
um you know his aunt still lives there
his uh his uncle has since passed away
like since I wrote the book
but um he's like call them and talk to
them
like without me there and they will tell
you the exact same story because they
were there also
so that's what I did I called and I
talked to them and they told me pretty
much the same thing uh that he told me
so I was like oh this is really
interesting so I asked him do you mind
if I write a book about it
um and it had been many years I mean
this happened in the early 1980s so it's
not like they were trying to like cash
in on the [__] they didn't want to tell
anybody I mean because they just thought
you
even at the time like I said in the
early 80s when it happened they were
just kind of like everybody will just
think we're nuts we're just not going to
tell anybody about this so it's not like
they were trying to cash in on it or do
like Amityville or anything like that
um the only reason was because I thought
it was a great story and I thought it
would be I thought it'd make a good book
and like I'm a horror writer I had
written a couple books prior to that
like fiction and I was like do you mind
if I write it down it's like you know
just tell me the story and I can
interview your aunt and uncle and
you know and I'll turn it into a book
and he was kind of reluctant but he's
like nah you know maybe we maybe we
should it's been a long time and stuff
like that but he's still like he was
still kind of weirded out about talking
about it he's not anymore but
when we were working on the book
um if we talked about it for too long
like he would get weirded out about it
he's like I don't want to talk about it
anymore you know what I mean he'd get
like that and like I said when we were
working on the book which when did the
book come out 2017 2018 something like
that and while we were working on the
book and we were talking about it all
the time and we were calling Lois and
red and
talking to them about it and then we
started having minor
Paranormal Activity happen in the in our
old house yeah nothing like what you
know what happened like when you were
younger but sick I mean you know enough
to be like what the [__] yeah what the
[__] is going on like just it it was
[__] like the TV would come on by itself
all the time
um the garage door opened by itself and
the garage door like the big garage door
and also the door from the from the line
from the laundry room into the garage
that opened and closed by itself
um we had uh doors open
the back patio door opens well it was
still alive while it was had the
deadbolt on yeah uh we had that like I
woke up all morning and it was just like
wide open even though we never opened it
and
um we had like some statues like fly off
a yeah pull down off the top of the
[__] remote control like threw itself
off a table Yeah in front in front of
Witnesses in front of like several
people yeah we had friends over that
night yeah and they were just kind of
like what the [__] uh yeah so [__] like
that would happen
um but I mean nothing that's happened
here just not yeah just it's very it's
been very I haven't seen anything here I
saw it but you saw it because it's like
another thing that it did you didn't see
us playing damn Mad Max video game and I
saw the drapes move like wind had blown
them
and there wasn't any wind in the house
the [__] everything was shut you know
this [__] never does that but I was
playing
and uh in in the view was that little
um
cabinet yeah the Victorian cabinet
and I saw them
plastic shot glass that I used the
measuring cup that I used to use to make
E-liquid out of remember [__] Vape
yeah when you were vaping yeah I saw it
[__] streak from the top shelf down
the bottom shelf and hit it and hit and
go and vibrate and I hit pause and I was
like what the [__] was that
and went to go look at that measuring
cup and it was deep inside the shelf so
it had fallen through all the damn
shelves
yeah because there's like no way that it
could yeah it didn't come out and then
go in and then go back in it went right
through them I saw it streaked out and
hit and land on its bottom and then
vibrate for like several seconds
and then stopped I was like oh [__]
but it didn't scare me it doesn't scare
me like it used to
well the weird thing about it is it
doesn't scare me either because because
of all the discussions we've had about
it it's just phenomenal it's just you
yeah it's psychokinetics so like I said
as long as you're not mad at me and like
I said we're gonna wing a cement block
at my head or something she felt it
watching she felt it watching her one
time yeah that's true yeah
and you know what I had you remember
when a couple years back when you were
in Mississippi yeah visiting your dad
because he was having the bypass yeah
you weren't home
I was in the bathroom brushing my teeth
or something like that and I could have
sworn that I felt
somebody you somebody like come up and
like put their hands on my like hips
yeah probably me
yeah
and I was like what yeah see I I've had
out of body experiences and near-death
experiences too from motorcycle
accidents so all that kind of stuff and
you can't force it to happen it just it
just happens
yeah I mean whenever it happens around
here it's usually when we've been
talking about the [__] a lot or when
you're real mad about something or
frustrated about something or
frustration or fear yeah or something
like that but you always have to be like
spaced out and like not thinking about
it yeah I gotta be real relaxed and when
it happens the phenomena happens I won't
notice it until after it happened other
people notice it they'll kind of snap
out of the huh what oh I guess that did
happen didn't it yeah because that's
what happened with the room yeah
you weren't even you were just like
space yeah no the conscious mind but me
and Jenna Dimitri saw it it happens when
the conscious mind is kind of like in a
lull you just kind of
slow down you're not really the
conscious mind can't do it like some of
the [__] you see in [__] Star Wars or
Darth Maul is pointing at something and
throwing it like that with his mind it's
not like that at all man I wish I could
do that [__] no it's quite the opposite
the less you're thinking the less you're
thinking and the less dominant your
conscious mind is the easier it flows
and it mostly has to do with negative
emotions for me although I can do
positive emotions too but it takes time
you have to do like Transcendental
Meditation and but it's going to end up
manifesting itself as out of body
experiences I'll just leave I'll see
visions and [__]
so uh but I haven't done that in a long
time
because it's kind of like cheating and
it's uncomfortable to do it because
um you're going to start to have to face
certain parts of your psyche and certain
parts of yourself not all of me is good
a lot of me is bad
and those things struck and attack you
you're dealing with demons
but what makes a man is to have these
monsters and these demons and learn when
to unleash them and when to keep them
chained up Jenny knows exactly what I'm
talking about they're besides of me that
are very bad
from military and contract type work and
stuff so part of me is like that thing
out of venom
yeah yeah he could he could relate to
that movie yeah yeah I made you what you
are you know and that's why we thought
let's kill this person you know that
kind of stuff and I'm just kind of like
hey this is this is just like you yeah
this is a good time to cut that person
to cut that guy's head off
I hear it say things to me I know it you
know but well and it and it gets worse
too like it's it kind of Ebbs and flows
with the with all the um you know gear
that you're on to yeah steroids make it
worse yeah big time yeah well depending
on what depends on what it is depending
on what it is yeah Tran I was I became
the Green Goblin
yeah you were like Spiderman you were
like a Monster yeah like not I don't
want to go that far and you weren't a
monster but you know I was nice to women
I wanted to get it I wanted to kill me
you didn't do anything bad to me no but
I'm just saying that um
Soph came over to visit when I was on
that [__] and I was actually I had been
on it for five months and she she said I
was terrifying and I was fighting in the
clubs and [__] yeah
they deserved it I mean yeah I mean they
did have a cup yeah but it wasn't like
it wasn't like it was unprovoked yeah
you know what I mean yeah but um but
yeah yes violence and sex starts to
merge into one Things Not only am I
[__] trying to
kill these dudes in a way I'm there's a
sexual element to it you're like which
is kind of the way I think the way
serial killers are you know yeah he
started going like they're like you love
it you know it's like BDSM you love the
pain and the suffering yeah you're
seeing you know it's and that that
[__] certain part of me in there is
just hey what reason why Tran does that
is it [__] stimulates your limbic
system which is like The Reptilian core
of your reptile brain yeah yeah and
you're very instinctual and it's about
sex and violence space emotions yeah so
you start acting like a Double Y
chromosome male you know you [__] so
I made him like promise not to take that
yeah I don't take that I mean there were
some good things about it like and I've
told you that before like I did like a
couple of things about it but yeah real
sensitive and simply towards women and
you're like but most of it was kind of a
nightmare yeah
most of it was kind of a neighbor like I
said you didn't do anything bad to me
I'm just saying like other than being
real they were scared of me because I
was was talking about like I'm gonna
[__] kill that dude you know you do
that kind of [__] a lot well you
couldn't take you anywhere because we
couldn't take you anywhere because you
were just like it's like well if we take
him somewhere is he gonna end up like
ripping someone's head off and then
we're all gonna go to prison you're very
strong on it you're very fast and you
don't think about what you're doing
[__] Trend isn't in control at least
I was and I was on a heavy dose of it
for a long time the longer you want it
the more it takes over not everybody
they got some guys that just can thrive
on it but not me
yeah like I said I was okay for about
you turned into like a nut I was okay
for about three months then month four
and month five I was
if you're a West Spider-Man
and you're not stupid you're intelligent
you're just evil yeah
uh what was what's that guy's name that
what's that actor's name Willem Dafoe
William Defoe I was William defoe's
[__] Goblin
yeah
we are what we choose to be you know
misery misery misery and you've chosen
the path you know what kind of weird why
be a hero that kind of scent you're like
that it was like that yeah
so you become very Machiavellian
Machiavelli yeah yeah a real violent
like I said not an experience
the sex is great though
sure the sex is great but other than
that not so much I'm here to light you
up not so much I got these little I got
I wear all these little werewolf motifs
and [__] after that because five years
of five months of trend you kind of pass
the werewolf test yeah and if I could
because you're you're a werewolf
basically yeah yeah we feel animalistic
that's why we gotta started talking
about werewolves yeah because that's
what you really like yeah that was like
werewolf
oh my God super funny all right so um
holy [__] it's getting so late yeah I
have to I have to go to bed soon I have
to get up at five in the morning
um and it's quarter past ten at this
moment so yeah hopefully you guys
enjoyed this uh discussion of the Latoya
Amin's haunting case uh this was
actually a fun one I was I've been
wanting to do this for a long time so
I'm glad we finally got to do it so like
I said if you want to watch the
documentary it's actually like pretty
good you know and I don't really usually
like that kind of thing but I thought I
wasn't bored it was like pretty
entertaining it's on Amazon Prime if you
have that like you can watch it for free
it's just called demon house with uh
Zach Bagans yeah Biggins Baggins
whatever I guess it's Vegas
I'm not going to be an [__] about it
anymore you're being an [__] right
now just making the fun of that that's
what yeah that's a lie I'm probably
still gonna do it but you know you know
what I mean
it's just because Ghost Adventures I
just I don't like Ghost Adventures but
yeah
um so yeah we will be back on
Friday night for the Sidetrack show so
hopefully you guys can uh come around
for that because like I said even though
yeah we do a lot of sidetracks on this
[__] too but on Side Tracks it's all
sidetracks so we can talk about we're
going to talk about all the [__] that we
experienced on our first time streaming
on streamate so that should be exciting
like all this all the stuff that we had
to do I mean we didn't have to do it I'm
just saying I was just interested by
everyone's requests you know what I mean
so we'll talk about that a little bit
too also Friday night is momentum
Maureen yeah so we're gonna have to go
out afterwards so
um so yeah but uh yeah hopefully you
guys have a good rest of your evening
have a good day tomorrow we will see you
again on Friday night for the soundtrack
show good night